the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club Ironclad defense has been on
display at the singfield cup in S Lewis
besieged Kings remained safely locked in
their castles as Relentless attacks
bounced harmlessly off the ramp Parts
medical reasons forced Gian sharof Duda
to abstain from round two shifting Focus
to the four remaining matchups Fabiano
caruana had multiple opportunities but
failed to take advantage of his
adversaries mistakes settling for a draw
decisive results remain elusive who will
be able to catch a break and win round
three of thrilling chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to round three of the sinkfield
cup we are here in the Central West End
close to the war Chess Hall of Fame and
SLE chess clubw it's a beautiful day
outside and hopefully we'll see some
beautiful games today let's go to the
studio and get
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the svi cup day
three starts right
now hello and welcome on this
Thanksgiving Day and so far we've been
treated to a feast of chess battles but
no one seems to have broken the deadlock
will this all change today I don't know
maybe it will I International master
evang guska and as always it's a great
pleasure to be alongside these two fine
gentlemen grandmas yes San and and
grandmas Peter fidler Happy Thanksgiving
everyone absolutely Happy Thanksgiving
only time will tell if the deadlock can
be broken hello everyone and Welcome to
our live coverage of the singfield cup
as mentioned players have been fighting
very very hard they great efforts but
accurate play has saved the day and we
have all
draws Joy do the honors and tell us
about the standings nothing changed
since day
one that may be in terms of the
standings but there is some huge news
yesterday the game between Richard
report and Yan Kristoff dudo was
postponed because Yan Kristoff was
feeling unwell but as you can see there
from the standings Duda has withdrawn
after round two because of ill health so
of course we wish you the best of health
and a speedy
recovery and uh what was the official
word on the withdrawal of Duda and uh
there you can see the official statement
that uh he's withdrawn from the
tournament his first round result result
will be voided and future opponents will
be having a buy that means they won't be
playing the game that they were meant to
be playing against Yan Kristoff and the
tournament will be played out of eight
points instead of
Nine the format doesn't change at all
but just remind everybody of the format
yes and despite this withdrawal it is
still a 10 player round robin officially
and the players will be playing at the
same time control 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves 30 minutes for the rest
of the game and of course the players do
have that 30C increment time bonus from
move one and my favorite part no draw
offers allowed and we have a standard
Point scoring system one point for the
win half point for a draw four games uh
per day but tell us about the schedule
yes so the players will be playing one
round per day that may not sound like
that much but it is an intense hard
fought game and today it is Thanksgiving
it's round three and the players will be
playing all the way through to November
the 30th but mark your calendars because
on November 26th that is players rest
day got it thank you Joy and Peter like
we say the players have been fighting
very hard but all the games have been
drawn they have yes uh so far nine games
have been played one of those has been
voided but no matter how you count all
of them have been drawn and you can find
all kinds of narratives if you would
like for uh for that occurrence there
you have the graphic and I would like to
go from the bottom up you can absolutely
talk about fatigue most of this field
played in the rapid and Blitz rard rort
came here immediately after finishing
the European teams uh Anish giri played
the Qatar Masters and so on and so forth
uh but I think the main major two
reasons are the ones above above fatigue
there first of all unbelievably strong
tournament and the players there's very
little to tell them apart in terms of in
terms of skill set and uh in in games of
between players of equal strength draw
Remains the most probable result and
then of course variance I could Rage
Against the vagaries of variance for
hours and end for various reasons uh but
it's just uh just as in 2015 all five
games in round one were decisive
and there was variance nine nine draws
out of nine here is just something that
happen statistically we shouldn't really
read too much into it there has also
there have also been very very big
opportunities missed so we we have
already seen that things could go
differently uh and on that uh somewhat
sad note I would like to switch to a
more pleasant occasion and welcome
Anastasia Carlovich the woman Grand
Master happy thanks Thanksgiving
nasta thank you Peter Happy Thanksgiving
to everyone then today we have a holiday
but we still but CH players keep playing
their games and um our social media of
course was booming yesterday when people
learned the news that young Kristof dud
that didn't appear for his game and our
official photographer Leonard Otis C
caught this really important moment when
Rich raer just learned that he's not
going to play in this round two and
young Christ didn't appear we know what
happened afterwards and now we know that
Duda will not continue playing in the
tournament and we wish of course him
speedy recovery uh but let's come back
to Thanksgiving our Arbiters decided to
celebrate it in style and they went for
running today 5 kilomet the Forest Park
turkey tro oh my gosh I mean I I saw
them after worse and um I have to bring
you the news everything is fine with
them they reached the destination and
Chris Bert the chief Arbiter of the
tournament came seventh on in his age
group congrat ulations to our Arbiters
they really they're really a good team
um so now on this note let's go back to
the studio Happy Thanksgiving yes sir
Joy and Peter thank you Anastasia and
likewise of course I love it the
Arbiters representing the Chess World in
the Turkey Trot go Chris go AR and tell
our viewers what they can expect for
this rounds pairings Joy do the honors
please absolutely set the table I will
set the table at the top we see Richard
report has the white pieces against Ali
Resa fuja Anish giri will be playing
Wesley so and there you can see that the
game between Dominguez and Duda has
unfortunately been grayed out Duda of
course withd drawing from tornament
right and uh Leon aronian plays ni piai
whereas Maxim VRA plays old rival
Fabiano Carana the players have been
fighting very hard yesterday was a long
broadcast as we see the players getting
ready for this round three the sad note
of course being duda's withdrawal here
at the uh on a Thanksgiving Day uh
unfortunately but what are there what
are they fighting for uh yeah honor
glory every time I see this graphic I
still get taken away you know first
place
$100,000 as well as 12 or 13 Grand
chestor points second place
65,000 Place 48,000 and say prizes for
everyone because his 10th place also
that's 10 and a half thousand a very
very nice thank you uh St Louis chess
club for your generous sponsorship is
there we see uh leavon and Napo getting
ready to do battle 11 Shades yeah I was
just thinking that I'm thinking that
there might be glasses that adjust with
the ligh to the adequate light yeah yeah
exactly uh Peter I mean commentators
curse all the way down uh uh we said
round one the most decisive rounds round
two the most decisive rounds yesterday
uh nepo uh had a an advantage on the
board but also on the clock and we were
just louding what a great player nepo is
when he's ahead on the clock and he puts
pressure and lanir just held it wasn't
yeah he needed some help though and uh
Yan very understandably uh I've spoken
to him since he's not very excited about
what he's done to his position there but
the tournament goes on and he can take
lots of positives out of that game
because he uh lir was extremely well
prepared got a very decent position out
of the opening and then got gradually
outplayed andan continued finding uh
small chances to put put pressure on
lineer and eventually uh from opposition
we were all absolutely certain will be
an easy draw for in year he he got to a
very very winning uh situation then
failed to convert somehow there you go
uh I have uh mvl versus Fabiano fabbi is
just been having an absolutely
absolutely marvelous year he's leading
the grand chestor coming into the SFI
cup obviously uh it would require an
epic failure uh by him not to win the
grand chest tour and the strange part is
this matchup could play a very critical
role just imagine just saying yeah we
calling we we we calling our shots now
right right this is the moment to do it
didn't you make a prediction right MV
needs to win this game all the games
could be drawn then mvl would be first
uh fa and then I think we'd actually get
a grand chest or tie the crazy part
because of the withdrawal and uh here we
have it Bishop E7 uh fabbi still not
play continuing to not play his course
against mville and this actually brought
back memories because before and I'm
sure his course is much more updated and
generally Fabby I would trust more in
terms of opening Theory than I would
trust myself but uh somewhere in the
middle 20110 like around 2015 I actually
recorded the course on the archangels
really and then a few months after the
course came out I played it with black
against mvl and I was in some trouble
but managed not to lose when when mvl
basically knowing what I'm intending to
do had had sort of very targeted
preparation
one of the lines in the Fab declining so
far to paint such a huge Target on his
back and continues to play other things
I've no as a trend that once you've
released a course or a book on a certain
opening you tend to avoid playing it
just because as everyone and as Peter
mentioned you know everyone is looking
at your course they know what you're
going to play else are going to judge
you if you forget your own
recommendations have you ever written an
opening book oh God yes
uh the caroan and I I I I back my words
uh by playing uh these variations and I
actually love it when my opponents come
prepared and uh they target me and uh I
get a chance to outplay them or refute
them by the way we're going right and
they're not even fabbi is not even uh
hinting that he might have played a
marshall he just plays D7 d63 yeah he's
done this in the rapid and Blitz as well
and we assume mvl will play H3 here mvl
is not a 9 D4 player and in the rapid
and Blitz fa played the classical Trier
in starting with Knight A5 Bishop C2 C5
here he might opt for yet another
somewhat he also played Bishop E6 I
think in one game right so he continues
jumping around and today he goes for the
uh for the zit of variation with Bishop
my goodness so a lot of jum around
covering a lot of ground here yeah wow
zitu is one of my absolute favorite R
luses I've played a lot of it with black
in my in my youth and and also with
white uh D4 I expect Rook E8 and there's
a lot of very very interesting and
actually very varied positions uh you
can get here the structures U are very
very but uh interesting I just wanted to
mention one thing with the blacks move
order if you play rookie eight as you've
got as played
white can force the draw well not force
the draw but initiate that all Chestnut
yeah anat kpof in his career he had the
zitu as his main principal defense
against one4 and a lot of players did go
for that uh Chestnut as you just said
the repetition uh famously in the game
between John vanderville and anat carof
the players repeated the position four
times neither player claimed the draw
then John played Knight D2 and the game
continued after was the game drawn uh
eventually but after the for move
repetition was assu uh do we have rookie
yes we do reminds me of the old story
about two two English men eating frogs
Yeah uh no I don't know
that one Englishman offers a I don't
know why Englishman but it's an
Englishman in the story I read is offers
a vager that he will eat a live frog for
a for for a pound and proceeds to do so
and earns his pound and then the other
one says okay now I would like my pound
back so I would I would like to also
propose I eat a frog for a pound and
that also happens and they look at each
other and they they ask themselves why
have we just eaten live
frogs for for for no money exchanging
hands at the end of this transaction so
why not just continue playing
953 just to get some extra time in the
this the crazy part is in the number of
the zits that I remember from the 1990s
especially the world championship match
between anatol kpof and Gary Kasparov uh
some of those lines were incredibly
sharp and they went very very deeply
Peter uh thear the sharpest line here
would be uh starting from from here and
then we go Bishop C2 the point of theid
of just to stop there and illustrate a
strategic idea of black setup is we are
aiming most of our pieces at at E4 Pawn
making it very difficult for white he
would very much like to play Knight D2
G3 here but if if you if you try to do
it in in legal ways right you you do
lose your Central Pawn straight away
which is why the major move here is
Bishop C2 to which black replies by
taking taking going Knight B4 Bishop B1
there are other moves here rather than
C5 I myself I think played this line
quite a bit you can also decline to take
on D4 there's all kinds of Sidelines
available but the absolute main line is
C5 D5
uh 97 right and this is an unbelievably
complex position which has been
discussed as yes I correctly said
famously in in a bunch of games between
K and Kasparov in their early matches
right and uh obviously theory has
progressed a great deal since that's
what I wanted to ask what is the current
state of theory I think people hold I
think uh the absolutely crazy lines have
disappeared I think the first of all
when I played the Z of with black I very
much liked playing A5 here because
because I felt uh the move C4 which garu
always preferred although he played A5 a
little bit but he mostly played C4 I
didn't really like studying the The
Unbelievable amounts of theory that come
from here and also like lines like the
one which I think currently is very very
topical they were annoying me because I
felt that even if black actually ends up
holding which I think is the current
state I think this position is supposed
to be okay for black we are really only
fighting uh for equality it didn't feel
the positions after F5 become absolutely
crazy very very quickly uh whereas this
is a much more controlled environment
where it feels like we're playing for
two results uh in the meantime Knight G5
is on the board I'm pretty sure we will
not have a draw here but just just to
mention that mvl decided to save uh two
moves get closer to the time control he
is not going to repeat uh so I think the
current state is uh as is often the case
uh the
machines uh support almost anything and
say you haven't really made enough
mistakes to lose yet right uh but you do
have to defend a slightly unpleasant
position I could be wrong I haven't
really returned to this material in
detail uh recently one of the one of the
really great lines if you don't mind uh
it it goes with the it's the A5 line not
the C5 not the move C5 um you take we
yeah you you take take A5 Rook Rook A6
and this this was the novelty of the
year and I really remember this vividly
it was in New York night
h23 because I had been working with Yan
Timon and also uh analyzing this
position with John Fedor and a number of
other Grand Masters and you know we were
always focusing on Rook on A3 to E3 you
know trying to blast our way through the
center and it was this move Knight H2
and then the followup move F3 yeah the
idea isn't as it might look to bring the
Rook over to G3 and give mate right the
idea I I can't remember exactly which
move say G6 it does the idea was to play
F3 and then and and this frees up this
night on D2 because the pawn and E4 is
now completely protected giving white
time to play Knight C4 perhaps even
Knight F1 take the Rook out play B3
Bishop B2 whereas for black now that
we've removed our typical normal
counterplay that you get in his Z you're
kind of stuck looking for ideas and that
first game uh Gary won very very
convincingly I'm sure BL can be improved
but right uh there was I remember that
game and that was a very stunning yeah
but the whole idea of Knight H2 followed
by F3 when our Focus had always been
like
M uh that was fantastic other games uh
Joy where would you like to take us and
uh let's go to the top of the table
maybe Richard report against Ali Resa
fuja he hasn't played in a long time
this Richie Rapport has I mean he's
probably feeling the rust day absence
absolutely well what we have is once
again uh E4 players are really having a
hard time everywhere you look whether it
be in the berlins or in the Russian
defense you have obstacles and uh here
Ali Raza playing the Russian defense
Knight C3 takes and remarkably for me
the theory in this particular line seems
to just have exploded and Peter Knight
B6 is not on my radar it's not on
anyone's I was about to say yeah and
nobody else's either yeah Yanka screen
screen is the one that has previous
games currently there is nothing there
this is a very very novel approach this
position obviously is tremendously well
well studied black plays I mean KN of
six I think is the most topical move of
course these days but you could also try
other things but I have I have never
seen the Knight being put on B6 engine's
initial reaction is why have you done
that you're in trouble yeah but I'm
pretty sure this is not a misclick and
Al has a a clear idea behind it uh for
white I would
just rard will now probably think for
quite some time because you do need to
figure out why your opponent placs his
pie on such an awkward square right but
in a Blitz game the bishop would already
have been on D3 I'm pretty sure right
because that supports the the two plans
that white have here one very obvious
plan is to play something like H4
followed by H5 or sometimes even
followed by Knight G5 and then direct
assault uh on on the black king side and
also just ping The Rook on Ean and
saying I have better control over the
Central files is also perfectly valid
and yeah as I said currently I'm not
entirely sure what is going to be the
supporting idea maybe Knight A4 whoa
once you know having said a kind of
thing you know we've played Knight B6 so
we have to justify it somehow the idea
of bringing it over to C5 we could have
done this in one
tempo but maybe there is this idea of C6
followed by Queen B6 I am somewhat
grasping at straws here because the
engine suggests playing Bishop G4 and
then of course not taking on F3 because
opening the opening the G file for the
white Rooks generally doesn't end very
well you it looks like the structure is
completely ruined but in fact the pair
of Bishops the pawn gets up to H5 so
that you can never really react by any P
pawn moves and then you start pushing a
lot of pressure on the G7 Pawn this is
bad so the engine goes uh currently at
least goes Bishop H5 G4 Bishop G6
but I would I would really hate this for
black like 94 95 looks very interesting
H4 H5 looks very interesting it feels
like we're getting an absolutely dreamy
version of these types of positions
where normally you need to work really
really hard to get to get this much this
quickly yeah and how do these players do
in their head-to-head J oh well we'll
find out I don't think they played that
many games and there you can see just
one win for Richard reports two wins for
Ali Rosa fuja and three draws okay I I
have this vague recollection of that one
win coming in the candidates yes uh the
one that rard won I think was a very
very interesting game that he won I have
a feeling with the black pieces even but
right uh they all somewhat merg together
in my in my head but if I can play advoc
for just a moment Knight D6 Bishop D3
Bishop E6 let's go yeah let's protect
the actually it says let's not protect
anything yeah I really wanted you to
play B3 so I could go A5 and you I was
thinking this a constru because I kind
of seen this idea of Knight B6 Knight A4
in a carakan but there you know you need
C6 and D so
C6 you want to go take the pawn okay B3
a this this sometimes works actually but
let's go but maybe not here oh I wanted
you to take my
Bishop Peter you're not playing ball I
am refusing refusing to play ball here
yeah King takes A2 a takes B3 I'm pretty
sure would have been very very good for
black instantly yeah yeah this where
this is where I was trying to guess D5
is winning is Queen D7 may be also
winning but but yeah the the point is we
have time to play Rook A1 and it's still
like it looks still the king is on B3
but now it has the C2 square and we have
preemptively controlled the a file so
this according to the engine is nowhere
near enough compensation for the be okay
and can you play very provocatively
instead okay well I know the whole thing
is I was
provoc that was a nice trick actually
that you showed us there Bishop Tes a to
I didn't know that one but I was okay so
after H4 could you do something cuz
Knight G5 is really annoying I'm curious
about s because the engine does suggest
playing B3 so what happens if let's say
we go
9735 this is interesting because uh it
gives white a huge Edge after A4 but you
have to wonder why why we're not doing
this I guess the king is it's it's
actually good that we haven't played
King B1 yet because we're going to be
hiding it on D2 that's a nice move Queen
E3 making a lift for the king and the
Rook is not on E8 yet the queen looks
somewhat vulnerable on E3 but black
needs a couple of moves to start start
explos it and it seems like they're not
going to be in time because there's
Bishop B5 even King G2 here works
because the queen will have squares
along the third third rank but this
maybe gives us a bit of a window into
how this might work right because if
Queen D7 actually successfully provokes
B3 I'm not entirely sure why we're not
playing KN G5 it's not taking on A2 it's
just playing Bishop F5 here right this
again
G takes okay once again now we see why
the KN is on B6 there are checks from
from C4 or D5 squares but this looks
risky I don't know machine says it's
fine but machine says everything is
fine yeah it it does seem suspicious
that like this uh to my eyes plan is
quite simple right you just leave the
Knight on
g51 yeah also I mean we probably want to
play Queen A4 so it's understandable
that it includes B3 and now even more
shockingly it suggests that even this
position is fine
wow which I mean I understand the
argument being made we will be H7 is
vulnerable but we will play Rook F7 it
will be very nicely protected the KN on
B6 actually once again controls
important squares there will be also an
eventually these two pawns will come off
the board and they will be a very nice
F5 Square for the black heavy pieces but
yeah this is you need to know dangerous
you need to know and immediately you're
thinking about Queen sacrifices on D6 D6
on D4 and long diagonal
but the thing is you need to know but he
does know it's his novelty so he will
have a very intimate understanding of
which position he can go for in which he
can't so right uh apart from Bishop D3
we can obviously start with H4
immediately there's nothing wrong with
stff it's it's a very yeah as Yer is
saying it's you you do this in pretty
much every single position in these uh
variations of the Petro could the idea
also be revolving around queen8 cuz I've
seen that idea I mean it was utilized I
remember long long time ago by humpy
Cano and she was to provoke yeah que he
just doesn't believe this is it seems
like it just fails to believe this is
fast enough here it even ignores A4 like
it goes Bishop D3 A4 and just says okay
like what are you says you've misplaced
your pieces so much I will somewhat
happily take with the c pawn put the
King on B1 Bishop G5 is already a very
very annoying threat and it would be so
much better if the Knight were on
F6
it really would yeah it really would
teleport it uh to square honestly a
somewhat mystifying decision but a very
welcome one because everything we're
currently looking at here seems very
sharp seems like black is intentionally
taking more risks than you normally do
in this line it's a challenge and this
is something that we absolutely have to
have to welcome absolutely and Richard
taking his time as he's addressing this
novelty in the old days we would have a
Time control of 40 moves in 2 and 1 half
hours followed by an adjournment so the
rule of the day the principle of the day
is when your opponent hit you with a
novelty you just spent 30 minutes yeah
thinking it over wow we don't have the
luxury today of 30 minutes but uh Richie
definitely trying to understand the
thought process behind this move let's
jump to the game of Anish G Wesley so
the players have actually reached a
position that uh has become suddenly
topical again Peter this is uh once
again the same anti Berlin that we've
been discussing during the earlier
rounds exactly we have already already
had uh actually we now no longer have a
pure burlin light cuz that game has been
unpersoned right uh that was the game
between Anish giri and and Duda in round
one which
saw yeah yeah it doesn't exist I I don't
know I don't know why I'm talking about
things which are entirely
imaginary but D3 Remains the more uh
popular move Bishop C5 Bishop C6 dc6
yesterday fa played C3 in this position
right uh this game follows the more well
trodden path here Knight bd2 Knight D7
Knight C castles first a people are
playing A5 in all of these positions
just fighting for space on the queen
side once again looks like there might
be you know better uses for your time
but uh Wesley of course is a very very
good specialist in this and so he he
feels this is the most important thing
to do for for now Knight C4 Queen E7 and
once again we see this move C2
C3 uh suggesting that D3 D3 D4 is very
much the order of the day like in the
leavon aan a Fabby game of yesterday C2
C3 with the idea of uh D3 D4 was still
on sacred Turf here I imagine I
thinkes some games for sure and I have a
feeling I may have even seen this and in
particular this line
uh Rings some Bells B5 I think B5 is
required but after B5 you're supposed to
be completely fine because you don't
actually have a particularly good Square
for this bishop you don't really want to
put it on D6 because you might actually
lose it right it it runs into trouble
and uh putting it on on this diagonal
Bishop A7 white could very seriously
consider maybe even Knight on e4 is
hanging yeah Bishop A7 is also playable
but you do have to now at least think
about the PA A5 hanging uh and this is
why I think they start with B5 uh this
structure looks really strange for a
second but then you realize both E4 and
C5 are hanging so yes it's not really
very beautiful but black will have pce
activity and also probably will be a
pawn up in in one movees time right yeah
and for now let's take a look at the
record how do they match up there you
can see everything is even three wins
three losses for Anish G and wzy so and
22 draws now at one moment Wesley's like
maybe number two player in the world so
I would have thought I mean Anish has
always kind of been in the world's top
10 but not at that very highest number
two so I would have thought that Wesley
had a little bit of in an edge not at
all to Eyes to My Eyes the surprising
thing there is I honestly would have
thought they would have played more by
this point they they are such a
you know part of the furniture part of
the furniture in the top 10 for the past
I would say 10 years maybe eight years
they would be playing in the grand chest
they would be playing in tata of Steel
they playing Norway CH classical games
right so still you know they would have
played an awful lot of games against
each other on Rapids and Blitz and in
their last Norway chess encounter it was
a draw in the classical game and then of
course in the armagan game that Anish
Drew with black pieces and took the
points I see Anish pacing uh are you are
you a Pacer or do you have sit FL at the
board Joi I'm I'm a Pacer I need to I
need to walk off that nervous energy I
need I don't even need to ask you I
Peter you're always walking around
looking at all the games I I just wanted
to say that Anish gave this impassioned
speech uh I think after round one uh
about the the fight for Supremacy in in
in terms of the best prepared player in
the world right he is but he he doesn't
mention it very often these days but he
is very easily the the Nazi dresser in
in the Chess World right he holds that
title for I I always want I I'm partial
to leavon uh leavon he makes his pass
his fashion statements as well
absolutely but IE he looks very Dapper
in a more classical sense because Leon
goes in all kinds of directions I also I
also love Leon when he's at his most
flamboyant but Anisha is your your
picture of a uh classical
D risque really yeah we should ask we
should ask Derek he wear t-shirts saying
catastrophe I knew catastroph
catastrophe with a picture of a cat and
I'm like you're not priming yourself the
right way uh Castle Joie is this uh is
this the most popular movie in this it
was actually the only move that had been
tried by black in the database and
funnny enough there aren't too many
games here no one has played the direct
D4 no one has played no you mean I've
got to be uh the flag bearer and and
show the novel moves out the way rookie
one has been tried Queen C2 I'm not so
sure about and uh H okay Rook e one I
can support I mean the idea is very
simply and and number of lines where
we've played D4 Peter's boldly pointing
out that the E4 Pawn can get tagged by
the queen so a preparatory move like
rookie one certainly deserves attention
you said Queen C2 Queen C2 and B3 my
eyesight was failing me B3 is another
that's been
tried that one's not the most natural
Queen C2 maybe Rook E1 yes and D4 yes
but actually I'm just looking at the
ratings of people playing this and no no
GR Masters have tried this one as white
uh Peter in uh the games of yesterday
were um with Faby and leavon I have to
remember the names you had mentioned
several times that the bishop needed to
go to G3 needed is a strong word but I
think you know the the yeah the the
fashionable solution is to bring it yeah
I should take rookie one back you can
still do it here but yeah but here I
think we've wasted so much time on
things which aren't very Central to to
our plan here that after let's say B5
followed by
A4 the point of this plan is to do it in
such a way that D4 will actually provoke
ed4 strongly enough but here black I
think quite happily will preserve
preserve this shape and without the
central pair like if you if you cannot
provoke ed4 fast enough and also even
even if if you can if you compare this
with what Fabby got yesterday I think
black is happy for very very happy
for the amount of space that that he
already got and the engine prefers this
position quite seriously for black
actually wow okay uh with with all the
space uh and it's understandable we just
burned too tempy right the night went to
C4 and then returned to this is there
ever a possibility to maintain the
tension in the center for black and
because I somehow I old burn that old
game rather burning in my memory you
know where black goes G5 I think it was
from Max Ira's middle game book where he
talks about going G5 and saying you lock
down the porn break uhuh so no F2 F4 for
you we're just going to keep somewhere
here yes I mean I'm just thinking well
you know IDE the idea is that you know
maintain the T you absolutely can I
think G5 is a bit is a bit too radical
but you absolutely can play some move
like Queen E6 or H6 or Rook E8 I guess
or Bishop B7 maybe even it's fine but I
think white will welcome having a Target
and having a much more clear-cut plan
here because he will probably play Rook
E1 try to get this Knight over to E3 and
yes the bishop on B6 looks very
promising but the stable situation in
the center and uh provides white with a
lot more clarity compared to the
positions after E4 CD4 and C5 is just
concretely very strong but even if you
don't play C5 even if let's say you
start with Bishop B7 Rook A8 and
eventually play C6 C5 these types types
of positions are much harder for for
white to control and once again
comparing this with the game Fabby
played against Leon yesterday this is
clearly much more attractive for black
because there's a lot of more a lot more
Dynamic possibilities uh black can Avail
the kns just don't have any good roles
actually right as I'm looking at the
current position with the bishop on C1
and the variations that you've been
showing me Peter where where Black's
Pawn goes to
A4 followed by B5 it's sort of like the
queen side gets lock down is there an
argument uh to be made for the move A2
A4 I think there's always an argument
for them for the move A4 uh black will
probably I don't know in which order I
quite like the idea of putting the queen
on E6 although specifically here it
apparently allows this uh tactical
detail which the engine very much likes
so let's start specifically so that we
don't blunder it let's start with B7 B6
right and then you want to put the
bishop on A6 once again suggesting to
White that this Knight on C4 is either a
Target or if it Retreats you've played
C3 and haven't played D4 so the pawn on
D3 will very much become a Target now
I'm warming to the whole concept that
you showed of B3 I kind of understand
why people are playing the move B2 B3 uh
and then we get to a kind of a balanced
situation where black with a Pawn on B5
obviously is not going to be pushing for
B6 B5 very much uh but I'm also not sure
what we want with white let's say some
position like this we exactly there's
going to be a lot of shuffling going on
if if we're talking about plans perhaps
I can uh play F6 and then get this
Knight over to E6 that would be an ideal
can I show one trap but okay the the
Trap is involving white playing B4 okay
but okay it has to be done at the right
moment so you want to play Bishop D2 so
say before going B I say say you go B6
it doesn't quite work but say you
instead of going B6 you or at some point
you might makes the pass move and then I
know I know Bishop G5 and Knight
F6 and then you get it my idea of going
B4 and then you go D4 yes although it
doesn't quite work of yeah there are
some
tactical but the point of chasing
close the point of chasing it six and
then creating this for is is very valid
and the fact that our board loves at us
should be disregarded right right right
right right right uh interestingly
Anisha is still thinking because once
again returning to to his I think quite
well substantiated claim of uh being in
the running for the most prepared player
in the world exactly uh Berlin will
never be a surprise when you're playing
Wesley
so interesting that he hasn't made a
move here yet especially as he's the one
initiating C3 and night C4 yeah it's a r
line and it seems to be his choice
rather than Wesley uh let's go to our a
final game that we haven't uh gandered
at and that's the one uh no that's no
that's mvl Le this is actually leavon
andan the only one that's opened with D4
so
already it's pulling out my heartstrings
wow uh okay Queen's Gambit uh declined
again in my day you know incredibly
incredibly popular uh KN C3 nimso
Indians were very very popular there was
one guy and only one guy on the circuit
that would play this quiet move and that
was Archer yusupov and often times he
left his Pawn on C2 for as well he would
just play E3
B3 the the old suer T yeah the say E6 E6
let's do it E6 not the collie sorry just
to pull you up the the collee you keep
but I played the collee my entire
childhood and the difference here as I
understand it uh if you play the kind of
a pure reverse Maron where you just go
for the for break MH let's say in this
position you put the pawn on C3 and then
you go KN B2 and like the the the
absolute central line of the colay would
be just a pure Maron with colors
reversed in White having an extra Tempo
something like this that's the col and
if you play B3 here instead of C3 which
is what this is the tuer Tor oh my God I
had it wrong the whole time I thought it
was welcome to the show you be happy to
happy to but I'm saying saying it was
actually very funny because we would
make fun of Archer and his you know
seizing the defensive with the white PES
then he just happily go and meet people
yeah yeah should be too he was very much
playing this playing this with the with
the you know bloodthirstiest of
intentions exactly and it's it's also
it's interesting how this is now very
much part of the taist Via different
MERS to a degree because people do uh
what they do quite a lot these days is
all this kind of stuff right yes with E3
yes uh and queen which is spiritually
very close to what to what AR will was
doing and often will actually transpose
later on so in a way he was you know he
was following in the footsteps of the
the Giants because tuart obviously
played World Championship matches and
right and so but he he also was the
foreshadow for the current opening TR uh
Trends but yeah E3 here if if we are to
explain it in the context of the game
between Leon and and uh yan yan had a
game in the rapid and Blitz where he
went for this line right and perhaps
leevon is unwilling to discuss it today
because it's it's quite sharp white I
think normally should get a little bit
of something but it's a line that you
perhaps don't want to play on the day
right so he's going he went E3 which
really isn't supposed to give you very
much because giving up giving up on the
uh the opportunity yeah to develop the
bishop on C1 outside of the pawn
structure to any of these squares
shouldn't be very much and he's
connecting this with a very very odd
idea to my eyes of just playing C takes
D5 here not even B3 Bishop B2 just c cd5
b D5 Bishop D3 uh played by uh by Leon
here this really shouldn't be anything
but these days people people very
happily I think aim for just a playable
position kind of disregarding what the
evaluation is and how do they match
Jo yeah let's have a look at their
head-to-head scores and of course these
players have played each other a lot of
times guessed wrongly yeah leavon has
two to pom's five I would have thought
eights I thought it would have been Even
Stevens to be honest with I thought even
leavon might have caught Jan as a junior
uh coming up the ranks but not not not
the case by the way B7 B6 and uh
developing
uh trading the light Square Bishops I
kind of find a little confounding yeah
I'm not sure also played it incredibly
quickly which is the interesting bit
here uh I suspect maybe he hasn't one I
don't really want to oversell this but K
has been known to uh sort of feel the
previous day's play Stealing his bones
on on dur Carri during the next round
and yesterday yesterday certainly hurt
him right because it's not often that
you miss such a clearly clearly winning
position and uh we were discussing it
live on air it was the last game running
and at some point there was this
position where I was extoling the virtue
of the move F4 uh and then I also
mentioned in passing we can perhaps just
for a second maybe some viewers have
not okay it's it's gone now I can't
actually do that do it uh yeah of hang
on a second maybe I can yeah I think I
think I can I can fig it out yeah the
king versus King it was the king versus
King at the very top I think yeah so uh
just those of you who missed the show
yesterday just for for the viewers who
perhaps have not seen this very dramatic
moment uh at this point uh ler had maybe
a minute yes Yan had about
20 and the engine was showing me that F4
is completely winning I could also see
that F3 is completely winning but the
somewhat upsetting part about this
position is that uh basically the move
that Yan play doesn't win pretty much
every other legal move wins including
for instance the move Bishop D3 F1 wow
so uh very understandably for somebody
who uh is a very very good technical
player normally and this is borne out by
the previous 20 moves because by by move
35 we were saying okay lineer is not
losing this exactly and he's and he
actually managed to get this Pawn from
D3 to D6 right and to create problems
for black and completely outplayed
linear from a position where I really
thought he has no realistic winning
chances whatsoever right uh but then
yeah the fact that he he ended up making
pretty much the only legal move here
which doesn't win will have uh will have
uh hurt him quite badly um but and
jumping into the game here because we
did see this trade of the light Square
Bishops Bishop A6 Knight takes A6 and
then if I'm on the white side I'm
thinking to myself I really need need to
play the move E3 E4 if I try to tuck my
Bishop on to B2 I really don't feel I'm
going to get any advantage uh so leavon
did play Knight E5 uh looking uh towards
occupying the C6 Square Bishop to D6
Queen E2 hit the Knight on A6 KN needs
to go back Knight has to retreat and
very
l34 uh and everything's fine until I saw
the move Knight takes
E4 which I find very surprising and I
don't know uh Joy is that move I mean if
you're going to take on e4 Knight takes
E4 doesn't no I think I think it's it's
specifically very logical in In This
Very context because you do not want to
be allowing in Bishop G5 this you don't
want to get the pin yeah this pin is
very very
annoying playing Knight takes C4 of
course involves having to calculate
let's say this position right but I
guess very very importantly you do have
the move C7 C6 because I was wondering
what Yan is even attending takes D5
right but after C6 let's say de Quin
takes D5 the engine suggests this end
game is pretty much fine you couldn't
throw in anything fancy like for
instance Knight takes B6 Bishop takes a
yeah we I know that Bishop takes a we
can compete in the
Desperado tra but here you know the
Knight on B8 is yeah but structurally
black is ahead you are correct about the
activity of the pieces but structurally
we really don't care about the lack of
the pawn and A7 the lack of the pawn H2
will be more keenly felt and also like
imagine eventually I get this Knight to
D5 n that's not a night that's not going
to
happen cuz the bishop will come to E3
the Fook will come to C1 and then I'm
going to ask you
questions yeah ignore ignore right
you're not threatening anything Queen H4
check Rook H5 maybe not yet but no
honestly the king will run I I would
start I would start feeling very very
nervous roundabout here because I think
black is a couple moves away from from
being seriously better um engine
suggests with a nicely timed A4 and B
before reminding black that maybe what I
said about the missing Aon is is not
entirely true right it says black isn't
better but I think most people uh would
choose to play uh to play uh black here
because and and if I do it in the
current position Peter a little bit more
conventionally I take on e4 Knight takes
E4 Queen takes E4 we just go Knight D7
and don't I get to occupy C six with
some I'm guessing Knight F6 is good
Queen F6 is also fine yeah Knight I
thought Knight F6 but actually it
prefers Queen F6 but I quite like this
let's say queen F3 I wanted to play
Queen E8 trade it on e4 oh so Bishop G5
G5 Bishop G5 Knight E4 is attacking all
of your pieces uhoh uhoh that's an alert
C6 is hanging G5 is hanging so you you
will get some kind of position like this
where yes this is a very nice square but
I've managed to get get rid of the
Queens we play Rook f8 I don't know
eventually bring the Knight over to D5
play F6 King F7 it's a bit empty I mean
it looks very beautiful but it's not
really hampering black all that much the
the problem I'm having is I have won
games thanks solely to the fact I have
this Knight sitting on this incredibly
powerful C6 Square so I do have this
baggage of this pattern I don't disagree
generally I just I just think that
specifically this is not the Catan this
Knight on C6 if once again if we return
to this position for a second he doesn't
really have targets and black is
incredibly incredibly solid So the plan
for black would be to put this Pawn on
E5 I think once again Knight F6 Knight
D5 is very much part of my play Rook
goes to E8 F6 King F7 it's just it's not
pressuring anything you don't have the
open C file the bishop on D6 is such a
magnificent piece as well yeah I'm going
to put this on my board because I'm just
looking at this position once more I go
Knight takes E4 I I'm just I'm just
mesmerized by this occupation of the C6
square and it just it just feels right
to me in
97 uh this move Knight here Knight to F6
this move Queen C6 Queen E8 and uh okay
I'm not thrilled about the move Rook D1
uh maybe you can go Bishop
D2 Knight
E I'm liking D5 D5 let's play queen4
anyway Queen E4 I'm I'm trading and we
reach this position where you know like
again if you get to play A5 before I get
to play B4 and give myself a Target I
get it um Rook E1 Rook E8 and then I'm
just asking myself is the night the
night looks pretty but maybe that's all
it is yeah I think I think it's just a
it's a very nice picture but it's not
really generating Prim Bishop knowing
knowing this is
so bad but by the way this is all moot
point because he's actually played
Knight takes D5 he did yes and uh now
it's decision time after Bishop takes
Knight Queen takes Knight in the center
C6 another big question here for White
is you know do you play Pawn takes
Bishop Queen takes E4 C7 Queen takes
Bishop the strange thing is it's this
feels almost reminiscent of some pet uh
defense positions that uh that that Yan
has assay in particular after D5 Queen
D5 there are some there are some
structures in the Petra which are very
very similar right uh I want to say that
Queen E5 I think is by far the most
toothless move you can play here because
after because after C takes D5 generally
with these Central pawns you very much
want the white Bishop to be a light
squared one yeah you would like to so if
we if we make if we make a few
indifferent moves here such as let's say
Bishop B3 Knight C6 Queen goes somewhere
yep uh let's say G3 Black Goes Queen D7
yeah um people have lost these positions
with white easily the uh dark squared
Bishops end up being it's equal for now
it's equal for now but people have lost
these types of positions with white
because the Knight ends up actually
being slightly more versatile here than
than the bishop so of the options left
has here this one I think is the
emptiest D takes E5 is something not
takes B6 is a very ambitious move
because it really just balances the
structure but I'll go with d takes E5
how how did we go natural right yeah I
think we take with the queen because C
takes D5 G4 I don't like that seems
dangerous okay so taking with the queen
M and let's just pause here for a moment
because he said he was afraid of Queen
G4 and is he misguiding us or is he is
he leading us to the promised D played
by the way he played D yeah he did play
D so we're expecting uh Queen takes
D5 Queen swap okay it maybe it's
toothless maybe not but let's let's just
see the queen Swap and Rook D1 no I was
I wasn't calling this toothless I was
specifically talking about Queen takes I
know I know I just like the word the
idea here though Peter is if you do play
Rook d8 and maybe that's actually your
no no no no no the intention here is to
go Knight C6 of course cuz Rook d8
Bishop G5 followed by Rook C1 and i' be
the first that is to grab the open C
file here you're required to play Knight
C6 as you were about to say whoa what
very interesting he took the pawn y just
completely disagrees with like
everything we're saying yeah
commentators curse I think it from the
very start where we came with all of our
beautiful statistics about the decisive
number of games in one it's been
downhill you know and I thought we did
it yesterday with Once stat Still
Remains what's that Lena Dominguez
undefeated as of yet
undefeated yeah yesterday we were
calling oh he's going to lose he's going
to lose no we were saying he's going to
draw he's going to draw then it was like
we were going to lose he were going to
lose and his commentators car D C6 takes
D5 Peter Queen G4 I'm assuming it's
Queen D7 or queen C8 in fact it's not
actually that bad specifically because
we have this option of immediately
knocking the the queen of the the
absolute perfect square on the board G4
is where it should be because currently
of course the big threat is Bishop H6
using the pen along the G file to just
win material right uh but both Queen D7
and queen C8 are playable Queen D7
already played Yan is playing incredibly
quickly uh today to the degree that you
have to wonder if maybe he is not
bluffing and he actually looked at this
for some reason but honestly I doubt it
I'm not I'm not really buying that and
and the point here is if you if you are
obliged to drop it back to G 3 you can
play something like Queen F5 Queen E6 as
well but I don't really want to provoke
you to play F4 I want to play Queen F5
first with the uh point being that I I
now have the move Queen G6 to defang so
to speak the move absolutely I'm very
much no attack anymore Dentistry
related similes today uh so Queen F5 and
and then we want to play Knight C6 and
once again if we if we make a couple of
pointless pointless waiting moves here
uh some some position like this will
start looking very promising for black
because the D Pawn will run and this is
a very nice Knight isn't the plan here
in these type of positions to run with
the pawns but the queen isn't the way
and with how few light pieces are
remaining on the board it's actually
quite efficient at being in the way you
can start with Rook D1 and then having
provoked Rook D1 now the machine goes
Queen E6 and says your four F5 plans are
much less efficient now because there is
no Rook on F1 let's say four Knight C6
and if needed we can also perhaps at
some point consider transferring that
transferring that that Knight over to to
F5 but I think maybe the simpler way of
dealing with the advance of the pawns
would be to prepare and push for F5 F7
F6 and yes in particular if you push F6
let's say just to illustrate the
structure this type of structure uh can
be worse for black because the bishop on
an open on an open board could be
stronger than the Knight but we can
organize it slightly better we can do it
perhaps already with the pawn on D4 so
the the bishop doesn't land on this
diagonal so easily uh seems like this is
entirely playable my my initial reaction
of this being dangerous perhaps has
been an overreaction an over reaction
and you can't play the the which move
the I'm just thinking about maybe going
once the queen steps back you like Queen
G3 yeah I'm thinking you have to protect
the E5 porn I'm just trying to get a
construction which is a little bit more
harmonious and flexible so I'm thinking
Bishop so and then Bishop E3 Bishop to
E3 yeah Knight C6 Knight C6
and unfortunately I was thinking about
gift me gift me your Pawn Yeah you can
include Rook D1 but I wanted Rook a to
D1 yeah I can I can it's probably the
best move in the position but after Rook
a d8 you're still uh question facing
facing the same question here yeah yeah
what are we uh it's really unfortunate
Bishop H6 I mean it's a slamming of the
door Queen G6 really just not only takes
away the attack it does so with gain of
time and what happens if white says you
know what I'm happy to let you trade I'm
going to go H3 this is H3 right now I
think it might be the best option white
has actually I like this one very very
much in the current in the
Cent okay I was sorry my mind had
already
rejected my Spidey uh just it's like
this engine grass where you know the
thing goes shooting through worry about
that please forgive me yeah yeah you
know you step on those elevators and
it's like 2,000 kilos maximum and then
H2 H3 okay yeah um so I have a a sneaky
plant the whole point is if you were to
capture the Queens H takes which I think
we do actually once I start to resolve
and protect the center okay the Target
is the H7 Point well that's a long long
long long line uh Knight to D7 so I will
attack your Pawn I'm trying to provoke
you to play F4 the reason I want you to
play F4 is I'm thinking that the Knight
might find a beautiful
Outpost yeah on on the E4 Square I like
the F5 as an outpost but because I put
your Pawn on G4 there's no Outpost so
Knight D7 in case you play F4 I'm well I
don't I don't think white needs to be
that worried about the Knight on e4 here
I will I will play4 quite happily should
I should I grab the open file though now
I'm thinking I can even E3 Rook to what
about Rook to D1 Rook D1 is yeah Rook D1
looks very strong actually yeah what
there's a Pawn on D5 just the second
second R to D1 I'm getting very excited
Rook C2 Rook D5 Knight C5 Rook D2 and at
this point I'm expecting you to switch
sides yes yeah I will uh I I I I dropped
the pawn okay so I guess it does mean
that I have to play Knight C5 and you
want actually actually it doesn't but
once again the way the engine proposes
to solve this problem is maybe not very
intuitive it goes Rook a E8 after F4 no
Knight D7 F4 Knight D7 F4 Rook A8 cuz
now the engine wants to play F6 no no no
not4 it goes Rook a E8 allows you to
play Rook D1 okay goes F6 and then Rook
F7 that's what I was asking yeah so we
we've included Rook E8 to make sure that
F6 cannot be met by 5 E6 of course
that's why the tempo was spent on that
and now after Rook F7 you actually have
to return this Pawn because e f Knight
F6 just doesn't look right right so you
go Bishop D2 okay uh F E5 Rook E1
there's still some pressure left but the
engine suggests this is very very
holdable um
this is also the thing that is happening
with modern chess is that the engines
are driving as deeper and deeper out of
the openings into the middle games and
uh you know there I think we saw Yan uh
getting up and kind of strolling around
he plays very quickly to be what not a
move we considered at all H2 H3 had my
attention but Queen takes D7 and Yan
quickly returning to the board to make
the only move uh following the mark
dorety rule play Force moves immediately
Queen takes D7 Knight takes D7 and
gaining a Tempo against the F uh pardon
me against the E5 Pawn it's the same
position but the pawn is on H2 instead
of G4 so Leon is making the argument
that in some variations in some
variations it would maybe hang right and
we have actually seen one variation
where it would hang where it did so uh
maybe
I I still feel like this is uh well this
feels toothless yeah not not the way I
would have gone but the position remains
you know for how seemingly dry it is
there is a lot of uh uh potential
intricacies here because white obviously
is now threatening Rook D1 the pawn D5
is vulnerable right and the ideal setup
involves something like putting the
bishop on E3 one Rook to D1 one Rook to
C1 and if black has done nothing by that
point you will have pressure and I won't
do nothing I will play what uh the
engine like Rook E8 Rook D1
F6 Rook takes D5 Rook takes F7 I agree
the pawn is not hanging on G4 anymore
still not it still doesn't take it says
yeah it says the very very same position
is actually a bit better here compared
to without the from the pawn is on H2
not on G4 and you can understand why
because uh very of often I think in this
in particular if once again let's
compare uh if if you go H3 and then you
aim for the exact same end game just to
right uh just to show yours comp the the
very little deta details and differences
which top Grand Masters have to contend
with in this position yes the engine
actually just says don't want this Pawn
what I do want is to get rid of the
active Rook on uh G5 and your your
structure on the king side is so broken
up
that I will always have counterplay
against it it doesn't really give white
any significant Advantage at all imagine
the same end game with a Pawn on H2 okay
it's it might still be holdable because
the blockading Knight on E6 will be very
very strong but your winning chances
increase I think dramatically if you if
you're allowed to make the move G4 H2
here gotcha so uh this this would be the
comparison uh black isn't obliged to to
do exactly that you can play just sort
of very simple chess Knight C5 Bishop B3
Rook ad d8 let's say mhm Rook A1 you
make a move F6 is playable Rook E8 is
playable you don't have to go for these
very conrete variations where you
actually give up material to achieve
your aims because we reached a position
I think that's very Salient to the
entire discussion if I play F7 F5 uh
here because my dream as black is to go
Knight E6 and I've got this great
blockading knight yeah we're taking
either aasan or the Knight I'm never
allowing never one thing that doesn't
happen here is we pass and we allow you
to put the KN on the exactly so
aan and how how is the evaluation here
Peter unsurprisingly in an end game with
equal material three pieces left yeah
around zero and Bishop takes C5 with the
protected pass Pawn in the middle of the
board same story should still be
holdable but you you have you have you
have the stroke lift towards let say A3
A5 like something like this right it
gives you maybe a little bit of pressure
if if you are to pick a sight here it's
probably white you want to be white but
should still be around equal yeah I I
also had one question to ask so instead
of playing Rook to D1 what happens if
you were to go Bishop to D4 and
blockade and Mah idea is that if you
were to go Knight E6 I just go Rook D1
and I wanted to ask about this
particular rook and porn end game if you
were to go Knight takes Bishop which I
it feels I don't think we do it
immediately I think we at least I play
F6
you'll you'll take on F6 I'll take on D4
you'll take on D4 I take on F6 and this
Rook ending really
feels evish it's it's once again a bit
better for white for sure we put G we
play G3 we bring the king over to F3 but
against good Defenders I think you enjoy
much the better of it you enjoy the you
are clearly the side pressing but out of
the 10 games starting from this position
between two players of this caliber I
guess the vast majority will be draw
okay all right very game there and we've
just had some news that the Richard
report game against Ali Rosa fuia is
getting very interesting so we left it
when after the move Knight B6 exactly
when Ali had deployed that novelty
Bishop d as Peter wanted uh D6 D5 a move
we didn't look at our Focus had really
kind of been on the Move Bishop E6 Maybe
even with Queen E8 ideas to maybe even
with A5 ideas but D5 was his choice H4
Richie is playing all the correct moves
Anda says do your worst go for your
knight G5 business shall we do it should
we have a look obviously we have to dive
into this one Knight G5 gift me the pawn
on H7 so I'm assuming we want to avoid
G6 yeah we pretty
playing G6 that gives me if you play G6
I mean you're giving me such a a
marvelous marvelous Target I wouldn't be
shocked that Knight takes H7 and H takes
G6 is a winning threat so I don't assume
it's G6 no it's pretty much always H6 I
think H6 yeah H6 and presumably you
would leave that Knight on G5 no retreat
in Frank Marshall style leaving it there
um I was actually just having a
conversation with myself that went
Knight H7 Bishop takes H6 I think
believe myself I think the issue
probably is Knight H7 C4 C4 right and
then after Knight takes work you've got
P takes Bishop exactly that fell on f8
is trapped I was so happy with myself
that I won an exchange until I realized
as you just said the Knight on f8 is not
uh coming out so no Knight
h7s um no Bishop H7
checks well you can play it I don't know
what it does uh just in more general
terms uh it's very interesting to me to
to
to I'm trying to get you to take my
night guys yeah now will you give me the
solid and take my no but hang onang
you're threatening a
nasty very very so for instance okay say
black makes a like a Duff move like A5
or something okay a Duff okay is it a
Duffer Duffer yeah I guess I don't know
maybe I've been watching too many
Simpsons it's it's rubbish move uh
that's very British rubbish rubbish yeah
I wanted to play the G we have to show
that and you know you can take one one
minor piece at a time but because the H7
uh square is covered twice then you'd
have to end up playing a move like F5 or
or uh G6 a move you did didn't want to
play Bishop H is it ridiculous this
variation in particular is bringing me
to to the point I was failing to
articulate before we went on for for
that rabbit hunt uh alza is basically
playing this line as it's supposed to be
played right but with a knight on B6
instead of F6 F6 which would have would
have rendered all of your play
completely impossible
H7
so fantastic risk taking in my opinion
this is a very very very new and a very
sharp approach and I'm a little bit
struggling to articulate to
myself I I can see why the KN on B6 is
worse than the KN on F6 why is it
better uh probably something to do with
Knight A4 que B6 that's the only
explanation I have because uh otherwise
you would really much rather have it
helping to defend your king because
there will be threats they will come
reasonably quickly uh these these lines
uh are quite sharp and you you never
have a particularly easy time of it here
with black so very very interesting
concept here by by Resa because uh we're
missing a very very big defensive piece
uh for currently very unclear payoff um
I'm forcibly reminded of uh willom
steinet say idea is science based ideas
were that when you have too many pieces
Defending Your King they're not active
enough and so you you you tried to have
the minimal number of Defenders so that
you could play moves like Knight A4 and
queen B6 Peter and if the Knight wasn't
needed on F6 then it was misplaced I
mean it it's quite the argument because
I'm looking at Knight G5 again Richie's
playing all of these moves and you know
whether you're playing G4 or whether
you're playing
something it it does feel like you're
giving me a free shot at the king side
can I ask something yes and I'm assuming
we've all assumed that Knight B6 is like
some offside no novelty could it be he
just simply forgot no no not not this
early stage that's first of all not this
early and secondly you never you never
play a move like this quickly if if
you're suddenly unsure of what your plan
is I don't think Al is a type of a guy
who Bluffs just a completely random new
movie right okay uh we've reached that
uh time in the round where we check in
uh with our friends of sing Phill cup
before we're going to do that we're
going to take a quick look at the
standings yeah let's remind ourselves of
the standings after round two so after
eight draws well that means that there
is nothing to separate on nine players
and there we can see everyone is on one
point barring Richard reports
who sadly could not play his game
against young Kristoff Duda after young
Kristoff Duda was unwell and remember
young Kristoff has now withdrawn after
the second round it just means that all
the players will be getting Buys so we
will have four rounds uh four games of
play per round instead of the five that
we had uh expected and trained ourselves
for yes and uh trying to get a smile
anyone wondering wondering why Anish
giri only has half a point that's
because
his game against Kristof dud in the
first round has been notified it's been
vo exactly uh okay now we're ready uh we
have reached that uh stage of our
broadcast we're uh time to check in with
our friends at Q Boutique stl.com and
see what they have for us this one is
this year sinkfield cup can keep you
warm for years to come with this
amazingly comfortable jacket and it
really is very very comfy I see the
players uh just kind of uh zipped in
featur Fe an embroidery 2023 SFI Cup
logo on the left breast the St Louis
chess club logo on the back of the neck
and the 2023 Grand chest tour logo on
the right sleeve the Jack is in stock
for both men's and women's Styles and
I'm telling you the holiday discount is
ridiculous you're getting a 20% off uh
and you can do all your chess shopping
needs at Q Boutique it's li.com it's a
limited offer so hurry now to the web
page
way said that that he went
into uh the chess shop and he said it
was it was great to be in a shop that
was dedicated to chess items and you can
spend a lot of money to absolutely and
we are going to take a quick break but
during the break we have a very nice
feature on the community outreach
program so enjoy that and see you in a
few
[Music]
minutes
uh so today's Community Day all the
parents of the US Championship are going
to schools around St Louis and you know
teaching kids um openings end games uh
tactics doing some fun stuff like hand
and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chess
whether that be critical thinking
decision- making skills planning skills
and I see them applying that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in classes or sports or even just
how they interact with one another and
with their teachers I play with my
auntie my mom my sisters sometimes on
the weekends like we go to the park and
we play they be begging me to teach them
I like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have fun and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my full career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life so I always want to
make bad decisions in life I can tell
you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytically at moves and trying to
think ahead I like the um complex of
Chess how you have to think about every
single move you make like every move you
make whether it's going to put your king
in check whether it's going to put put
your anything in
danger whether it's just a move that you
make everything counts in the long run I
like um how it makes me use my critical
thinking makes me look at the whole
board I think it's teaching them to be
persistent you know we have a lot of
students who it takes them like it may
take a few weeks or even months in chess
club to master a particular strength
strategy or skill um and what I think
that teaches kids is even if they don't
get it the first time around or even if
it's difficult the first time around um
it's worth sticking to it well one
thing's for certain without the St Louis
chess club we would not have chess
instructors because I don't know if you
all know this but there is a critical
shortage of teachers and Educators and
especially those in areas that are not
core content area and because of the St
Louis chess club collaboration we have
people who come in here working with
students who want want to work with them
today with the experience of the
grandmas community outreach day I came
up and I'm like well what's a grandm and
they like oh you don't know what a
grandm is and they were able to explain
that and they recognize the importance
and the seriousness I mean it's a sport
it's a profession and so they're able to
see things outside of the sports that we
typically promote in school makes me
feel good because like learning stuff
like this will help me learn help me
build my problem solving skills help me
build strategy and like you know help my
[Music]
brain hello I'm women's Grand Master V
janua I will be creating content for
Grand chest store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping gr schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chess in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Rex sing I would say that
S luia Club is like a rock in the ocean
of chess and we know that it's it's
there it is there it will be there I
think it sense a hope that the game of
chess will always stay Float by the mere
fact of its existence I think it it it
sends positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's ground
master ranoa I will take you behind the
scenes of the gr chest T follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup up and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family-friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
awardwinning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit worldes
h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
qo Boutique and all purchases go right
to benefiting new exhibitions and
programs at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy
welcome back to our coverage of round
three in the sink field cup and it's
been an exciting start to round three
some tension on the board and let's
remind ourselves especially for those
viewers who have just tuned in of the
standings after round two and well there
we see it there's not that much that
separates anyone no one has yet won a
game and yeah you can see Fabiana Carana
and a whole list of people there on one
point and uh let's remind ourselves of
the pairings and there you do see that
the game between Lena Dominguez and Y
Kristoff dudo has been grayed out and
that is because unfortunately Yan
Kristof Duda has had due to ill health
to withdraw from the event and in those
four pairings we see a very nice one uh
between mvl and Abby and let's just jump
to that that was a Zev and uh when we
left it uh we were very curious as to
which line of the zit uh Maxine might
choose uh the old think had always been
that A2 A4 was the most challenging A2
A3 I have it in mind that Alexander
bosski was one of the first to come up
with this idea of just giving the bishop
an extra Square on the A2 Square Peter I
feel like MBL actually played this
against uh against me at least once
maybe even twice but it the games didn't
go uh the way the way of this game A3 H6
is uh almost always required there are
some very uh dangerous traps you can
fall into uh if you postpone this for
too long and AOW 9 G5 in the uh in a
favorable variation in particular can we
show the one the one trap say for
instance the Knight goes to
D7 ah D7 let's say 9 bd2 okay oh I was
just you want to Bishop here here it's a
different one there is a there is a
reasonably well-known position like this
where if you play Knight B8 you pretty
much have as you can see the immediate
bottoming out of the engine uh and some
very very high level games have been
lost by this by this line this is a very
very well-known trap where we we take on
F7 and black is so ill equipped to deal
with the eventual attack on F7 you can
TR you can take on D1 and perhaps you
would think I could get the pawn to C4
and this will force white to cash in the
chips on F7 no C5 white plays Bishop
E6 maintaining the bishop on the Diagon
and now the best play that black has is
to play Knight C6 and Knight d8 after
which you will have to defend what
frankly is a losing ending a losing end
game after something like Bishop B3 you
have to run away with the rook and then
white will protect the pawn on e4 and
will eventually convert there have been
Grand Master games and more than one
that have been lost this way nice uh so
this is why you want to play H6 sooner
rather than late and I B2 Bish fate
played and I think uh against me and
they was playing D5 in all of these
positions but today he went for a very
very slow buildup this idea of A3 Bishop
C2 it exists and now we are at a
Crossroads because very often the one
bad piece that black has in the zes of
if white doesn't do something very
immediate in the center is this Knight
on C6 which is really sort of in the way
of your own counterplay and we also have
to well not have to but we would like to
continue preventing the knight from
landing on G3 okay so black plays Knight
B8 here with the same idea of meeting
Knight F1 with he takes D4 and the pawn
on e4 is hanging right uh so after
Knight B8 mvl played B3 Knight B7 Bishop
B2 this I would say this was somewhat
topical around
1985 and not really since you know uh
those were the good old days come on
yeah and black has black has all the
time in the world uh to to finish the
velopment F play G6 now white Play
Bishop D3 and A4 and this is what I
wanted to say this is an intersection of
zit and the Brier variation where black
plays KN B8 on on move n and after after
A4 here Fabby did something that I have
not really seen very often but it's a
very good reaction specifically here
this whole plan of playing A4 and Bishop
D3 as early as possible is aimed
squarely at trying to provoke C7 C6 the
pawn on B5 is hanging you do not want to
be losing it for nothing C and if you
play C6 then White's plan and this is
sort of a classical bre I think this
position actually transposes to the
absolutely Mainline
briers the bishop on B7 now looks kind
of sad right pushing 6 C5 will be
difficult white plays Queen C2 and
eventually the plan here would be to
play C3 C4 and start expanding uh in in
the center and these positions often
become quite annoying for black they're
not really bad bad but they're
definitely preferable for white instead
F just says
I have a pawn break in the center what
is currently what is currently
preventing me from this Pawn break in
the center is the fact that my Pawn is
hanging I will just spoil my structure
by playing B takes A4 positionally this
is of course not a move you would like
to make leaving yourself with this uh
straggler on A6 but I will immediately
blow everything up in the center with
the6 D5 and very likely there will be
mass simplifications now because this
this type of a for porn formation in the
center results normally in the entire
entirety of the the pawns here getting
annihilated I have seen the move d4
takes E5 being played by mvl and we
would in we are probably taking on e4 uh
because the recapture on E5 would allow
white to uh hang on a second yeah Knight
E5 Knight E5 Rook E5 C4 is playable F4
is also playable I think to a lesser
extent but C4 in particular is very very
annoying here first provoking D4 and now
we can even play C4 C5 to make sure that
black cannot black cannot support it
with with their own Pawn also Knight
this is this is a weakness and uh yeah
this is not great you you really don't
want that actually this position has
been reached before uh between ala fuja
and Liam leang and there Knight takes
Knight takes C4 Knight takes E4 and this
also I guess explains why fa is playing
this very very confidently this is move
20 move 20 after D6 D5 and normally this
is a sideline Fabio obviously is
extremely well booked up but honestly
this plan with A3 followed by B3 this is
very very slow and it is very much a
sideline so I would he would find all
the same moves but he would spend more
time doing it right uh only spending 50
minutes to get here I think implies that
he's seen this before so let me just uh
update my board but it looks to me like
the position's just uh blowed up uh D
takes E5 Knight takes E4 um how would
the uh variation continue Joy Knight
takes E4 D takes E4 Bishop takes E4 yeah
let me just uh pull up that game and you
mentioned it was fu yeah it was F fuer
against Liam and yeah so there were some
trades in the middle of the board Knight
takes
Knight yes and D5 takes E4 hang on you
take on e4 here with the bishop yes and
after Rook a a takes E4 you have this
very standard tactic for all of the
Spanish positions you can still take on
E5 with the Knight because you have an
intermediary check on
F3 that's exactly what happened
intermediate listen to him he knows
everything have you been studying uh the
games of Ali Raza Knight takes E5 and uh
do we take on d8 and you have the inter
meeso so if we take on d8 as you said we
we take on B3 with a check first we
don't have to recapture go GF and then
we take with the Rook on E so that not
BL very cleverly and at the end of the
day we do have to split pawns but okay
probably a draw but I would say a more
pleasant one for black and uh yeah this
looks absolutely absolutely fine and I
do believe we have Knight we just saw
there on our uh screens Knight takes E4
it will actually be difficult for them
to avoid getting to the position after
Knight takes E5 specifically after
Knight takes E5 fight has options
uh the game doesn't need to end an
immediate draw in that position but uh
like Queen E2 yeah Queen E2 or night D2
perhaps trying to preserve some pieces
on the board but the players are racing
and what happened what was the result of
that particular game that you were
mentioning between Liam and
unsurprisingly it was a draw but a
Haring of the point it was a sharing of
the point and uh we do have Bishop takes
what happened there is that uh White
success sucessfully managed to avoid
Knight takes F3 by simply playing Knight
takes E5 at the end of all the trades so
after Knight takes Pawn Knight takes
Knight Knight takes E5 and I'm assuming
Queen takes D1 was the answer to Knight
takes E5 s the vacuum cleaner onto the
board removes all the pieces and okay um
rookie five here because rookie five and
Rook C4 Peter yeah Rook B5 I guess Rook
B5
that's annoying yeah in this very end
game okay well this game uh sure does
look like a fizzle if uh they play right
straight into an ending I want to go to
the game of uh Richie and fua for a
moment something very interesting
happened there exactly uh very much so
so it seemed to us that Richie was
playing all these very nice attacking
moves H4 Knight G5 Bishop D3 got the
position with H7 H6 eventually by the
way the times are 42 minutes for Richie
107 for Ali Raza and a move bit of a
surprise C4 C5 I don't think it would
have been in my top 10 in particular as
is often the the phenomenon here is if
somebody shows you this position let's
say a friend of yours who is also a
chess player yeah sends you this
position and says guess the move this
immediately rules out all the natural
moves right in that yeah in that context
I think maybe I would have guessed it in
the top 10 right but if I were to start
considering from scratch without knowing
that I'm looking for something that I'm
not expecting right I don't know if I
would settle in this because Richie uh
enough spoiling we should show what he
played he played the move C3 C4 here
which is a pawn sacrifice uh and also
solves very confidently for black the
problem of what to do with the Knight on
B6 and also how to get rid of the bishop
on D3 which seems like a very important
attacking piece right because white
pretty much is oblig to uh to take on C4
and I guess the plan is to play Queen E3
which does provoke a slightly awkward
looking move Queen E8 but now that there
is no uh light Square Bishop on on the
board I think black will be more
confident in facing the attack one thing
I wanted to mention there's this
incredibly famous Alan game uh which I'm
forcefully reminded of but we don't have
enough pieces on good ah Bishop I'm
sorry that is a bit of a problem this
just wins on the spot I wanted to show
this very typical uh situation like
takes takes we go F5 and there is this
incredibly famous Alan game which
reached this kind of a position and Alin
won it by playing G6 and then creating
Unstoppable threats on the H file but
currently we only have one Rook on the h
f so like if we could play something
like if we had a king on B1 here and
could play like Rook D1 5 year that
actually would be made right but
unfortunately that's not how anything
works but the position is so dangerous
for black because even this position you
know you I'm looking at moves like Rook
D to E1 absolutely asking questions of
the bishop absolutely and you you have
to be one thing I will say though is
that there is this a flating available
which I already blundered once then you
go P takes I mean how Bishops of
opposite color Jo didn't round one teach
I think I think the most important
factor in this position is the fact that
the H3 square is covered because you you
cannot create immediate direct threats
here if you take on G5 you might
actually even maybe I mean you're not
much worse but you're also not better uh
if once again if if in this position we
already could create a mating threat we
would we would be very much in business
but because H3 is covered by the bishop
on C8 we are probably completely fine as
black so seems like there is no real way
for to break through I wonder how much
time it has taken Rich to settle on C4
it's an interesting option honestly uh
it probably will not uh produce a big
Advantage for him but it's a very
original option I utterly agree about C4
being original it would not like you uh
Peter been on my top list but without C3
C4 and like you said you know your
friend just ask you what am I supposed
to do in this this position what would
you have recommended to your something
like G4 what was an engine's top shorts
was it G4 G4 is good yeah G4 Queen E3 is
another move that it suggest Queen E3
yeah and one thing I wanted to to
mention here which I think is a is a
good way to explain how Richie arrived
at the move C4 right uh I think if you
give black the move here black is very
very interested in the idea of playing
C4 themselves because on H7 it probably
will get stuck and if you successfully
remove the Bishop from this diagonal
let's say bling B1 C4 let's say
something Bishop B2 suddenly all of the
ideas of Knight A4 Queen B6 gaining
strength Rook E8 Bishop F6 all of these
moves uh once this bishop is on E2 and
not on this diagonal there's pretty much
no attack on the king side anymore and
black has a much Freer Reign to start
something on the other side of the board
so I think it was prompted uh by the
realization that something needs to be
done about the idea of C 5 C4 and
actually weirdly I think G4 is a
prophylactic move not not an attacking
move the point being that after C4 we
will do this and we have an additional
Square for this piece protection we have
an additional Square for this piece
which is a huge big deal we don't have
to put it on a passive square and also
if it gets traded there is a g file open
for our pces so this is I think this y
G4 would be would be a good explanation
for why G4 is playable and in fact uh
computer with F7 F5 and I would say had
reard known that F5 was Reed that G4 F5
might be required he probably would have
gone for this position because honestly
at first glance it looks like this
cannot possibly be playable for black
you're being helping apparently it's
completely playable for black and in
fact white might even have need to need
to make precise moves here but you know
for somebody who does not have access to
uh the engine evaluation this looks
incredibly attractive I think because
bounding Joy is there any kind of
because I'm I'm just trying to make
sense of the C4 idea okay so take G
because that was played and I'm thinking
after Knight takes Pawn C is there any
currency in I was thinking Bishop H7
check and just saying King h8 King h8
and then Queen to D3 your idea and I
would be good but we're kind of B B3 and
then I just kind of wanted to check this
one out M there is there is
unfortunately a very direct tactical
reputation for it everything starts
collapsing I was wondering I mean queen
F6 wins on the spot my I wanted to ask
myself the question whether this is the
only move that wins and I can see that
Knight B2 also wins but it's Bas but
it's basically the same move yes so
perhaps apart from this idea of Queen F6
this maybe would have worked because as
as we've discovered Bishop G8 is a
massive threat you can maybe make can
argument that even the G5 Pawn is
hanging in some variations the Knight is
hanging to I mean you you don't really
dream of playing B C4 because maybe it
opens up your your own uh Queen side but
yeah there's a very very specific direct
reputation for it yeah thank you Peter
uh we're going to jump to the game
between leavon and because uh I don't
think uh that game is going to continue
for too long because exactly when we
left it we saw the move Queen takes D7 a
bit of a surprise for us right we recall
that we were looking at H3 and those
endings but Queen takes and the play
went Yan actually found a very very
direct way to try and simplify which uh
wasn't immediately obvious to me that
this works but I guess Leon couldn't
find anything so he traded off the minor
piece and played King Rook to D2 that
is I like that word yeah right a little
cheeky little move Rook to D2 takes
takes Rook to D1 Rook to E8 and these
guys are so accurate and that's what
it's been for the first two rounds I
mean this is not a smidge of an
advantage and up to the point where Rook
D2 was played
maybe there's one was hopeful there's
one specific point where he could have
continued but the evalation continues
dropping so we do not count this as any
kind of a Mis M it would have kept the
game going though uh specifically in the
position after F5 was replied to with D5
D4 right uh there was the option of
playing Bishop H6 uhhuh uh maintaining
the minor pierces yeah yeah maintaining
the miner piece is also putting the
bishop on a very very Obviously good
square right I'm pretty sure Yan was
intending to play N9 G7 to challenge the
the the white center and the engine
makes this very clever little move Rook
D1
D2 in order order to be able to a check
in order to be able to give a check from
G2 if black actually goes after the F5
Pawn that would be a mistake uh but
against G instead of gf5 gf5 here Rook
G2 followed by Bishop G5 just wins on
the spot this cannot be played at all
this is a nice one so you can't take on
F5 but Rook to D2 yeah Rook D2 engine
goes Rook D5 and says yeah nothing
really has been has been lost uh it
looks like the players are actually
repeating the current position uh J Jan
is smirking a bit because he could play
King of6 here and pretend he is a bit
better but nobody really does that no
nobody really does that
and you don't want to disabuse
uh Rook D2 plate a professional
repetition is
incoming the
draw uh
virus is amongst us as uh we they they
can't uh get away from this it it had
certain moments but it never really uh
came to anything even the least bit
critical uh Peter it seems like a very
wellplayed game there were some
decisions in the in the opening I you
could question uh honestly I feel that
uh Yan tried to equalize sort of
Hardcore equalize specifically like
somewhere here Bop a the engine suggests
that you can just play something like
this and
pris common wisdom is that if if you
play cd5 F5 this early with the bishop
still stuck on C1 black really isn't
supposed to be any worse at all so why
not just play a game of chess whereas B6
Bishop A6 it's a solid positional idea
leing white with the obviously the
inferior of the two Bishops right but
you spend a lot of time on it you have
to then put the Knight back on B8 as
we've seen in the game so perhaps Yan
played for a
simpler way to equal equalize instead of
playing for a more complex position with
all the pieces on the board but once we
get here it seems like an incredibly
wellplayed game just um leading to
equality yeah their accuracy of the
players continue to amaze I mean even uh
Joy you weren't here for the rapid and
Blitz but even some of those Blitz Games
could easily be disguised themselves as
classical games because they played just
so so incredibly well uh just going
again I just wanted to see if anything
really had happened between MV and Bobby
and the players have gone right down
that whole ending with Knight takes E5
and uh we've been looking at uh Knight
takes E5 ourselves and that move Rook B5
what Peter showed that was really
annoying excuse me this was this
position with Knight takes E5 I we we
didn't really finish our thought but it
was a I I I thought for just a moment
you know like I had played this move
Rook C4 and I thought okay if I can just
get you to play some defensive move I
don't care Rook E7 or Rook C8 I might
have a bit of an edge thanks to my
Superior structure but it was this move
Rook B5 Rook B5 I think is is a very
good reminder for white that the move
you actually want to make is the move C3
C2 yes yes this is this is the one you
want right you put the bishop back but
unfortunately E3 and play C3 C2 not
allowed not allowed denied denied and if
you have to play B4 well then that's
just going to get undermined by A5
exactly that was uh and the timing is
just perfect for Fabby and we're
thinking Even Stevens in this game we
just saw the game of uh that was drawn
between um nepo and uh let's jump to the
game of Anish giri and Wesley so for a
moment uh when we left it we left it at
these parts and we did see we didn't see
the move B3 but uh B3
was as actually uh in the theoretical
database Peter take it away B3 so after
Rook E1 uh if we go back to to here we
were discussing direct ideas of playing
D4 but right Anish did end up playing
Rook E1 Queen E6 is a very logical move
because he also very often will want to
bring that Bishop back so that opens the
rookie a bishop f8 Clans and also stops
D4 for the time being because the the
Knight will hang so B3 uh B5 chasing it
away and now they announced they announ
dropping back of the bishop is prepared
this is normally a very very strong
piece white generally is very happy when
you you can establish this uh Knight on
on the F5 square but there's really no
support in terms of any attacking
possibilities on the king side so
shuffling will uh continue until morale
improves as is well known and we reach
this position where the move G g76 is
really the first decision Wesley has
taken uh which surprised me because I
thought we don't really need need to
react to this Knight on F5 I don't quite
understand why we're softening our own
structure and uh the solutions that the
engine offered one thing to mention we
have just with black played F7 F6
leaving the pawn on B5 on prise because
if you take I will be able with either R
B8 or Rook A5 to win it back immediately
but after Queen C2 perhaps C takes B5
was already a bit of a threat and the
engine suggests that you can reply to it
in both of the slightly Unos
anti-position ways both B5 B4 and B
takes C4 are playable connected with a
very specific idea if white let's say
recaptures with a B Pawn what we want to
do is we want to land this Knight on C6
and then on D4 or actually even B4 in
some positions if there's still a
backward Pawn on D3 for us to play
against and the engine is entirely
unconcerned here with black uh there's
nothing much going on on on the king
side if the center is entirely closed
you can maybe sometimes there's you know
the old Classics where people play King
H1 they play Rook G1 and they launch
this attack but once the Knight lands on
D4 you will not really feel like there's
nothing going on elsewhere uh so that
seemed completely fine and in fact even
B5 before with the intention of playing
98 9 C6 also seems okay you probably
don't want to start thinking about
giving up the a file but it's in a cold
light of day it seems to be completely
playable not that G6 is a bad move but I
was a bit surprised about allowing that
six check because this gives white a bit
of a foothold can you not do the same
plan though you know once you move the
king I think I think you can yeah but I
just didn't feel like I needed to
comprom I I view the move G6 as a bit of
a compromise on the king side because
there's now a target for some future
play it it's it's very much in the
future there's really not no way for
white to attack the whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa cuz I would feel very uncomfortable
in this position with whites actually
because you know the Knight on H6 isn't
doing that much and if you go Knight to
G4 well they can always get kicked back
with H5 and I love your plan of going
like B4 Knight B8 Knight C6 and and
suddenly you feel like black has the one
that's playing for everything sorry to
the sounds the sounds I was making there
yeah sorry to interrupt you but the
bishop how did this happen let's rewind
we actually just completely blundered
Rook takes E5 this is how it
happened oh but but but Maxim didn't
Maxim saw that this exists a move that
completely eluded my my attention this
actually wins you know arguably wins
some material because black has to take
Bishop takes C5 otherwise Rook takes C8
wins material we take on d8 Rook takes
d8 and we took on E5 with a rook because
if you take with the Knight after F6 you
get a much much inferior version of what
we're getting in the game right uh just
to show why uh you will have to play
King F1 here and the Rook immediately
attacks and wins The Pawn on B3 which is
really really bad news for white so Rook
E5 Rook takes E5 Knight takes E5 a check
was given and Rook D2 played the bishop
the bishop came to
A3 and uh this was a rook versus the two
light rook and pawn versus two light
pieces but everybody's jumping for the
pieces uh Peter there is a very useful
uh rule of thumb here you can you can
use to to assess these end games which
uh is another you know little bit of
wisdom I've acquired over the years that
is not mine is not mine but I feel very
confident in sharing this very same
position you add a rook to both white
and black over white is pretty much
close to winning exactly specifically
one Rook against two light pieces is a
much better situation for The Rook right
because uh you need you need a piece to
compete for for the control of the files
and a single R can do things uh against
in particular against bishop and Knight
if this were the two Bishops why would
be much much better but Rook with bishop
and knight uh I think this is probably
around equal because the the structure
on the queen side is soft enough that
black probably succeeds in getting a lot
of stuff off the board on the queen side
and also you have to remember that uh
even three against three on one side
rook and uh Knight and Bishop uh against
Rook is generally speaking a draw if
there are no major weaknesses and two
against two is pretty much always a draw
right so if if you imagine in this
position let's say black somehow loses
the H6 Pawn but the entire Queen side
disappears that is a draw okay it will
be played out right you can occasionally
lose if you misplay it but it's a draw
so there is decent amount of uh safety
there available to uh to fa but I'm very
grateful for for mvl actually sporting
R5 because we we we have a game on our
hands right uh it is a game but the rule
that I have is that when it's just a
rook and a bishop and Knight The Rook
does very well well in end games because
the Rook is able to do something that
the bishop and Knight can't do Traverse
from one side to another in one swoop
sure no no question very very powerful
piece the difference for me though Peter
is I agree with you swap off all four
pawns on the queen side easy draw even
if I lose the H6 or F7 Pawn in the
swapping but in this particular case
with the
pawns uh weaknesses uh C7 mhm and A6
can't I play for example Knight D3 with
the very concrete idea if you play Rook
C2 or what about Rook go D2 very I was
thinking Rook A2 and go A5 A4 is that
just too
simplistic no so we probably want to put
it on also fine yeah let's where did you
want to yeah Bishop I was trying to the
ideal setup of course was my Bishop
coming and I wanted A5 just
to
yeah and I again if your pawns were on
B7 and C7 I wouldn't even be discussing
this as a Poss we can trade one it
starts liking it for wi now can you keep
that on the board because I'd like to
have that idea in my pocket maybe Rook
a or is it it's actually quite
instructive how how the engine treats
this it very much keeps this in balance
and it starts advancing uh on the king
site saying that if you lose we want to
make sure that G2 is if you lose the PA
somewhere you will be very unhappy and
once this reaches A4 you can also start
bringing your king in and also you
constantly ask white to keep an eye on
the queen side because well losing B3
will also probably be lethal for white
yeah seems like this is still balanced
but it's it's a sharp end game it's it's
very much a sharp game Let's interrupt
our discussions and uh throw it to
Anastasia with a special guest over to
you
Anastasia indeed I have a special guest
I have Yan B who just finished his game
against Leon Ronan the game finished in
the draw three draws so far Yan how is
it going for
you the
tournament hard to say so like in the
first round it wasn't
really um a full you know a full game
and yesterday was like a a long game and
yeah with quite an unfortunate final
moves uh yeah but today yeah I think I
misplayed opening very very badly so I
mixed up some ideas and
um I think at some point I thought like
it's like it's not like a Thanksgiving
day for me like it's like giveaway day
so like my position was like I mean at
least optically going worse and worse
extremely extremely fast yeah so it
didn't feel that way from outside can
you explain exactly the moments when you
thought the position was well first of
all U yeah you can even play like this
yeah like cded but this
is um not like anything
quite E really trying to achieve any
advantage just more like um trying to
deviate from
uh some known lines so it's like similar
position is n one then Bishop was on B4
well not not such a big difference for
black so I can do the same but uh what I
did was I tried to play this line with
Bishop A6 which is I mean it makes sense
but um I think the thing I mixed up a
little that there is a very similar
position in Bishop D2 A3 line uh but
then the bishop is on D2 D5 is not under
attack so the difference is like Knight
D6 uh Knight E5 so here probably I
should could played Queen C8 or
something anyway yeah like to make a
response sensible move L Queen goes to
E6 very solid yeah but okay of course my
idea was to play C5 but then Knight C6
Queen D7 let's say um takes takes here
and the pawn on D5 is hanging so
probably this
was also not that bad but you know if
you take with the Knight M white
unfortunately please not force it take
on to capture on D5 yeah so then I get
some nice compensation but instead just
played for asted Pawn like something B3
knight2 Bishop B2 and looks like I'm not
I'm simply not in time to deal with it
so it's like slightly worse for a very
very U long uh long term so here well
that's why I played Bishop D6 but yeah
clearly I I lost the trace I would like
Anyway the position is very solid so
probably it is but after Queen E2 I mean
it's suddenly quite unpleasant to choose
between like Queen C8 and um Knight B8
like both moves are not great uh there
would be a nice move Knight C5 but
unfortunately here Knight C6 Queen D7
takes takes and Knight okay Knight to5
at least so Queen A6 so it doesn't
work uh so I'm pretty much forced uh to
go I mean like Queen C8 was also a move
but um I think the problem is the same
like E4 and my pieces are uh quite
poorly coordinated so okay I have this
Knight C5 trick in in this moment but
yeah it's not that doesn't look great
either so
E4 well here I had a choice uh actually
I could also play like Bishop
E5 maybe it would be I mean even more
passive than what I got what I got but
maybe
slightly slightly more solid because I I
I'm not getting my weak Pawn on D5 but I
was somehow not to concerned and I think
I was wrong so here like Knight D5 is
principal Bishop B5 Queen E4 and
so yeah so C6 is probably the only move
because if I play let's say Bishop D6
series I mean I have very very slight
compensation here so for example if
Knight F6 Queen F6 queen8 Knight C6 I
think I'm doing more or less fine uh but
the problem that he can go some KN well
a lot of different moves yeah also like
Knight B6 a lot of moves here works yeah
yeah Knight B6 uh as well yeah crazy
yeah but yeah quite you know quite
logical so okay when you play like
Knight A6 B8 and back back yeah back and
forth it's not so good so C6 this was
pretty much forced so here taking with
the queen was quite principle but then
he takes takes Rook D1 Knight C6 Rook D5
Rook d8 uh takes and Bishop F4 so this
somehow I believe should be playable for
black but I mean still it's like the
pawn so not so great maybe I called the
draw here I mean most likely black draws
this but um because of the active Rook
yeah
like P5 is also weakness so but I I
wasn't so sure so I decided to play like
cd5 Queen G4 well Queen G4 I'm not sure
uh he had so many nice moves here like
played positionally in different way so
maybe Queen E2 was the move also but
okay Queen G4 is principal and here uh
well I was choosing between Queen C8 and
queen D7 I'm not sure so this leads to
pretty much similar positions like Rook
C2 takes Knight C6 but here he can just
I don't know like play like F4 or maybe
H3 or B3 like a lot of moves and I'm not
sure I'm getting full compensation as
well yeah so I was also concerned so I
decided to play Queen D7 but in fact
this position is very
dangerous so we exchange it F4 I'm not
sure so left suggested something like F6
uh E6 Knight C5 F5 and then D4 and then
slowly like play Rook d8 Rook D5 and
then G6 which maybe makes sense but it
was not obvious for me like at all like
letting this Pawn onra wi which probably
will be there forever looks dangerous
also yeah so Knight C5
Rook D1 maybe here I should have tried
other Rook to d8 uh but wasn't obvious
to me at that at that point so somehow I
felt like after Bishop E3 G6 if he goes
G4 then there is some mess and maybe I'm
um should be doing fine I was way more
concerned about some col call move like
Rook a C1 Knight A6 let's say
G3 and yeah the type of position would
hardly ever change and he just slowly
improves like comes with his King to F3
then okay H3 G4 so probably I should
hold it through with some precise play
but this like this is very unpleasant to
end game very unpleasant so like even
like play D4 Bishop F2 Rook A8 like I
don't know King
G2 and don't know let's say F6 takes
King F7 King F3 and so probably yeah
like slowly white trying to improve
but I mean this is nothing but uh but
Pleasant for black but here surprisingly
five D4 uh so here I thought like I mean
maybe just lost after Bishop H6 Knight
G7 F6 Knight E6 Rook a C1 so because of
like the backround problem so my king is
basically trapped but maybe it's not not
as bad as it seems yeah like I play
something like Rook A8 and um maybe I
play G5 and D3 so okay at least uh this
didn't really depend on me already so I
did everything I could to to get into
trouble but the rest was yeah Prett
pretty random I would say yeah and just
exchange here here the only only thing
that after E7 you have to play Rook D2
uh otherwise I think it's very very
Danger but yeah this is enough so after
King
F1 I I don't think I had anything better
than than what I achieved exactly so the
game finished in a draw I'm sure that
you noticed that one board was empty
today do the wiw officially from the
tournament so what do you think about it
and have you ever actually had similar
experience withd drawing from the
event uh you know I wanted this I wanted
to do this so many times you know
probably even yesterday I wanted the
same yeah like so uh I know you didn't
feel well also
yeah well uh also but yeah I guess it
should be something serious so I hope
like everything will be well with young
shishto so but yeah maybe this
tournament is a little bit you know
doomed so last year it was like like
some another reason but already after
three rounds uh one player uh decided to
withdraw this year is a different story
but already after first round
yeah so yeah happens yes exactly thank
you so much Jan all the best of luck and
the last rounds please stay with us till
the end thank you thank you thank you
Anastasia well there you heard it
himself Napo is doing his best to get
himself into trouble he didn't do it and
that uh brings us to our results uh
after uh this one draw but more draws
seem to be heading our way Joy Perhaps
Perhaps Perhaps but there we do see it
the the first result of the day between
leavon aronian and Yana pomi it was a
draw some very impressive analysis there
from the fori showing us yeah he might
have got tried to get himself into
trouble but he had it all worked out he
did uh one player who hasn't worked
things out very well F7 F5 a move came
out of the blue for me Peter uh and also
I I'm not keeping a close enough eye on
on the clocks to be able to produce the
exact figure but it feels like 25
minutes to play it as well pretty much
equalizing the the clock situation I
think uh ala was doing quite well on the
clock but see C4 clearly took him by
surprise and the reply is very unusual
because completely ignoring C4 and also
to a degree ruining your uh your king
situation yeah isn't Queen E3 a screamer
Queen E3 seems very strong it it becomes
very concrete though I've I've only just
kind of was alerted to this I I'm not
entirely uh you know up to scratch here
as to what's going on but Queen E3 looks
very obvious and even C takes D5 uh
which is maybe a less obvious move
because you need to to have the answer
to Queen takes D5 but yeah the engine
suggests Queen E2 here is unbelievably
strong followed by surprisingly B2 B3
and then Bishop C4 becomes a threat so
uh it now becomes a question of whether
whether reard can calculate this very
cleanly because it seems like the move
of five is very much giving him an
opening to try and exploit this uh this
shall we say speculative decision by by
lza and why did he play F5 what what
what convinced him that he needed to
make this weakening he disliked
something about Knight takes C4 but I
think until we we get to the player
interviews we will not really know for
sure what that was because I'm pretty
sure he also got here and I think if you
if you get to this position and you
realize that you pretty much always have
the bailout option of taking on G5 not
with the pawn which is actually working
in many cases but with the bishop which
immediately immediately gets the Queens
off the board as well yeah uh you
probably aren't going to be into in too
much trouble and it's difficult for me
to to believe that he's playing F5 as a
way to play uh that he believes that
he's has an advantage here so curious
decision I would like to to talk to him
about it afterwards well one player we
can talk to H Joy uh at Anastasia in
studio with leavon let's jump to
her yeah welcome Leon to the studio and
Happy Thanksgiving for you today is it
the first time that you are celebrating
this holiday in US yes yes what are the
plans well I have friends uh over from
New York so they're going to introduce
me to the Thanksgiving oh yeah okay so
it's going to be a great experience
today so but before that we had to play
you had to play the game and I feel also
like I'm playing with you guys you know
that's why say we had to place so what
happened in this one Yan mentioned that
he mixed up something in the opening so
how how did it look for you from your
side yeah I thought that uh Bishop A6 is
a bit of a dous idea and uh I actually
liked my
position um of course I have many ways
to proceed in this position I mean
Knight B5 is quite tempting generally I
mean just strategical but I thought this
queen2 E4 is very direct and could be
very strong and I kind of like my
position I mean of course white has many
options in this position you know uh I
was thinking of Queen D3 also possible
but I thought you know this end game
should be be very pleasant and uh like
you have this better Pawn structure yeah
so far I thought what I was doing made
sense but then I think G4 is a terrible
move I actually uh really missed this uh
D4 um idea because it was not possible
prior to that and then uh I kind of um
got carried away because my position was
so nice yeah I just should just play
Slowly you know just Rook C1 King F2
King to F3 and I think it's a very
pleasant position for white you know
just
uh not necessarily winning but
um like Pleasant it's an edge yeah it's
an edge you you can you can play Forever
yes can you explain I why why you think
that it's so good for white I mean
because some I mean we can see the
variation of the computer let's say for
example Rook C1 Knight D6 King F2
because I mean strategically there is
much more uh risk for black because uh
so this Pawn is easily blocked and uh I
I do have a plan to push with
F5 while uh for him you know it's it's
difficult to find like a concrete plan
So eventually you know I will push G4
and I will get what I want because once
the pawn goes to D3 Bishop B3 so Black's
Knight is not being activated and
therefore White's at
Advantage can be significant here mhm I
understand so let's say this G4 was the
critical moment of the game and after
that yes because when he played Knight
D6 I thought F5 I actually thought the
whole sole point of Knight D6 is to play
Knight G7 here mhm uh Bishop G5 Rook D7
I thought that this is this is what I
was looking at you know and then D4 I
thought this is very interesting because
I can play Rook E1 or Rook D1 and try to
play
E6 maybe I was still overestimating our
chances if it's
nothing um but I no it looks really
optically so good for what yeah yeah I
me try to play it with black I don't
know why computer is so optimistic for
black but it doesn't look so well yeah
for yeah somehow maybe I'm not in time
yeah but uh yeah after after D4 um yeah
I didn't believe in Bishop H7 Al I saw
that possibility I thought definitely
not going to work so decided you know to
call it a day just to just to play solid
and because this is clearly a drawish
position so and the game finished at the
end in the draw U how can you estimate
assess your participation so far three
rounds already finished the game with
swabi yesterday yeah it it was not one
of my proudest moments I I really
overestimated my position yesterday I I
thought that with uh the
Rook against the bishop I can never be
worse but uh because of lots of um
tactical reasons my my position is very
difficult to play so but then I really
got lucky yeah I like the moment when
you start pushing G5 you know still
hoping to create some quarter play was
like I think good attempt and five
somehow didn't find also the the correct
moves yeah there I you know I couldn't
be really second guessing there I I just
had to play something because it can be
very dangerous this type of positions
for sure and young Christ that withdrew
from the tournament today um what do you
think about the situation right now well
he's a brilliant player I mean what all
we can wish for is for him to get
healthy you know and uh I mean he's a
really really nice person and uh I look
forward to be seeing him in other
tournaments I hope
he will recover quickly yeah ever
happened to you that you were playing
ill during the tournaments or withdrew
from the tournament have this ever
happened to you before once I was on the
verge of withdrawing I got a fot
poisoning a terrible fot poisoning in
Mexico City in
2007 World Championship mhm and
um I decided to play but uh throughout
the tournament I would be just crying
I I I I would be just uh you know
getting in the resting area and just oh
my God just to cry yeah cuz I was
feeling so sick I I got um I think I got
some sort of a disent oh my gosh this
was really and you still kept
playing yes yes but just players they
never give up you know they always keep
playing I remember myself fever whatever
I would still come and play well you
know this was the my first candidates
and I qualified there by winning the
World Cup and after winning the World
Cup I had to play two matches to qualify
yes and I beat Magnus Carlson and I beat
Alexa shirov so how can you withdrew
from this yeah no it's not possible
right I remember also you haven't played
in SOI one time right that you had to
cancel but it happened before yes yeah
that time I was really really ill I
think it was I wasn't sure but I think
it was a CO
I I also think I got coover during the
Olympia in
India have a history here okay one
really all the best of luck for you stay
healthy everything should be fine and
Happy Thanksgiving once again and we are
going back to the studio to you guys
thank you Anastasia and thank you leavon
for sharing his thoughts with us he
looked a little bit more dejected
actually like he disappointed that he
didn't press as hard as he would like
part about it it it's okay making a draw
a wellplayed game but when you feel like
you had a very significant advantage and
then you didn't put any pressure on nepo
then you feel like you let something you
left a lot on the table Peter yeah he
did he did seem very disappointed with
he with his play I think more than he
deserves to feel I don't think his
Advantage was at any at any point as
significant as his face there was was
suggesting but still I very much
understand his feeling because is that
that description he gave to one of the
positions he could could have gotten and
didn't I could play Forever there it's
that's exactly what you don't like to to
to let go of against a very strong
opponent such as Yan when when you get
up an end game which you can press risk
free uh for for some time you feel like
you really should have uh should have
tried but he missed something tactical
and uh and then the game tell us about
the position this ending between mvl and
fabbi because this one is also like
likely likely disappearing because
Bishop C5 uh and V did what I sort of
expected him to do I thought Bishop C5
is a very good move apart from allowing
specifically Rook C2 uh Bishop D4 or
Bishop B4 but frankly if you want to
play Bishop B4 you never play you could
start yeah you're never playing Bishop
C5 to begin with Bishop C4 and this
break and after B3 B4 here the engine
suggests there's no even uh necessity to
do anything on the queen side it goes G5
for instance and starts pushing the same
plan that we were describing earlier
right there is D7 Knight B8 but the
engine says it doesn't really frighten
it very much but you can also make an
immediate drw by playing A6 A5 I was
curious about AES before but that might
lose maybe not actually the evaluation
does seem to suggest that in the time
that white will need to get the king
over there we will probably be in time
to land our King somewhere on the G3
square and make a draw yes gives gives
zeros currently but nobody really does
that because the move Rook A3 exists
right which is just much simpler right
just uh and the pawns will come off
either immediately or let's say you play
B5 and I put my Rook behind and I start
pushing my own passer and once again you
can get the pawn to B7 let's say you do
this you do this you play B7 and black
is not really threatening R B1 A1 but he
also will never play Bishop A7 because a
this will Quin so this is also a
position of complete balance nobody
really is doing anything here at all uh
so yeah I'm I'm expecting uh fa is
currently I think uh trying to figure
out if he has any real winning Chances
with a move like G5 MH and he has played
G5 so he he feels that he's running no
risks and can continue for a while which
is I think a correct correct assessment
of the opinion of the position but uh
draw is still a massively massively uh
favored result here okay thank you for
that so whilst this position looks very
balanced let's uh move on to another
position so I'm looking at Anish giri
against Wesley so and of course Richard
report against Ali Resa fuja that one
well your move yeah well I've been I've
been desperately trying to get in it I
thought Queen E3 you you you said C4
takes D5 was the I thought Queen E3 was
really the move that I found myself
attracted to but we didn't analyze it no
not really I I I pointed out cd5 because
uh honestly I I was surprised uh the
liked it okay and I just wanted to point
out that queen3 is not the only solution
but in terms of human moves you will
actually make with your hand sure I
think Queen E3 is very much top of the
list creating you know we we're still
dreaming of giving mate on the king side
but we're also threatening pretty much
to win the game with Knight D6 because
if that trade happens on E6 Square the
entire Position will collapse which has
happened he has played Bishop well not
not really because he has Bishop takes
B2 here okay ah and white needs to play
King B1 actually Knight D6 is very
strong and if reard reard clearly hasn't
missed Bishop takes B2 because it really
is the only explanation for Bishop F6
allowing Knight E6 just to explain if
you do take on B2 black will give a
check from F6 this is still quite good
for white right but the engine does
suggest that this provides black with
decent drawing chances this is not that
clear our King is now also somewhat
vulnerable and we aren't really giving
mate immediately we we have to you know
still do some some things to create
direct threats King one on the other
hand is very very strong
because you have to play Bishop D4 The
Rook on f8 is hanging any kind of a
romantic move like Queen F6 does not
appear to to actually deliver any mate
you can try some beautiful uh diagonal
threats but after C2 C3 providing white
pieces access to the B2 square if you
continue doing naive things a move like
queen2 here solves all of White's
problems and there is no mate uh so at
least the engine suggestion is to to go
back to
D4 after which white very simply takes
twice and with the Bishops controlling
so many squares and also C4 C5 coming
there will never be any serious attack
on the queen side and for white is just
a very dominant position this is an
unbelievably strong Bishop the black
Bishop you can put it on E6 but it has
no future on E6 your best move is F5 F6
absolutely you would very much like five
seven yeah should be so some position
like this it Frank it looks terrible
ruinous for for black yeah I'm shocked
it's not worse than it is on my
screen um very very sharp continuation
expected because 96 is already on the
board I also want to mention this is
move 15 right uh reard is below half
half half an hour mark and Al are
quickly approaching the half an hour
mark so we might have a very interesting
uh time trouble on a mutual time travel
in our hands wow Knight E6 it just looks
visually just so much Superior I just
didn't even consider the move Bishop F6
that wasn't even on my radar you can't
really defend against Knight D6 though
there aren't really good options you can
play something like Queen D7 but the
engine even just spends a Tempo on on
playing B2 B3 and says I have all the
time in the world is not hanging on G5
we put the queen on G3 we play Rook H E1
we are never now that black played a
five and didn't do anything in the
center we're pretty much never worried
about black taking on G5 so this is very
very oneway traffic according to the
machine okay wonderful well sh game
there thank you Peter and uh let's
remind ourselves of the results so we
did have one game decided that was
between leavon aronian and Yan Pachi
that game did finish in a draw Still
everything to play for in all other
games and it's time for us to take our
second break of the day but don't go
anywhere because we have a nice video
lined up you can enjoy earlier on
yesterday Anastasia covich she asked
napon about his encounter against lenia
Dominguez so have a
[Music]
look Yan welcome to St Louis welcome to
grest tour it's it's great to see you
here again what do you think in general
about State of Affairs in the Chess
World on the top let's speak a little
bit about it let's say ding absence
Magnus doesn't play so many doesn't want
to play he say so many classical events
um I mean there are some changes there
are you know some new trends like what
what what do you think about all this
new players new generation is coming
well Magnus uh you know last I guess
last year or something he's acting a
little bit like lanty
R uh of of Chess yeah so so I would say
we're not expecting uh I I think some
chess fans expecting something different
from him uh but I think he totally
claimed his rule you know to to his
right I mean to to enjoy yeah like to to
chill yeah not
to not to be as competitive as before
but still he's like insanely strong and
think um if we take like all all free
time controls alra G he's I think still
the strongest uh but uh his recent
classical results are still like quite
good but not as impressive as before so
maybe he would like to to work on this a
little bit and you know to get back to
his like uh top rating and top shape uh
speaking of ding uh well as far as I
know he's uh you know feeling not great
uh so probably he has some issues so I I
can like I do to wish him some speedy
and full full recovery and can wait him
can wait to see him playing again yeah
so some rumors say that it will be
already in but um yeah we'll
see uh so what else uh okay like uh you
know like always uh someone uh is
suspected to be cheating yeah others are
suspecting him yeah and so on so yeah
pretty pretty routine pretty pretty
routine stuff what about New Generation
let's say and also um their successes
and the fact that some of of the young
guys are playing in the candidates
tournament what you think Indians
Indians are you know you know like last
year I I expected to you know I expected
let's say usbekistan team to win in
Olympia or to play well in Olympiad
let's say in
2024 uh but they uh you know came faster
than I expected yes so it was like well
to two years two years earli than I
thought and also Indian Indian teams are
very very strong of course and it's not
surprising that uh you know right
now I guess there there are already like
two two Indian players in the
candidates so I would say that Gish or
pranda were expected there one of them
and Gish I thought that maybe Bas based
on the F the circuit he he would be
there but seems like uh Anish over
overcame him yeah the moment yeah at the
moment but yeah it's obvious that maybe
he's playing a bit too much yeah so at
some point I think last couple of months
he just ran out of
energy and yeah he I think he needs some
some time to recharge uh what was
surprising is that we did like uh U well
of course like
was like a well-known like player with
great TCI worked with lot of top GMS
here uh but yeah I was quite impressed
um when I played against against him in
the World Cup uh so to be honest I
expected him to you know to to perform
nor as well in Rapid section against me
but yeah well he he just played insanely
strong uh way way better than uh than I
could imagine yes so and uh that's quite
unfortunate uh I think that he was
stopped by abasov but what to do so
anyway he he played so so nice in um in
out of man uh well
but you know others others play other
players from India like young guys like
of course GES and Eric G and also I
think sadani in in couple of years uh
they are quite quite strong and uh I
mean they have all uh all you know all
the time in the world basically yeah to
to to work to work at at chess yeah to
to get better yeah so that's uh clearly
you know this happens sooner or later
then okay some young Young Guns young
Lads are coming yeah but uh you know
also our generation like '90s and 90th
and early '90s you know also not
so you know not so
weak still and and and not too old yes
so maybe for for quite sometime we can
we hold the pressure but uh yeah
speaking about yourself let's say where
do you place yourself in all this top
you know uh Chess World and do you think
you still have chances and are you
fighting to get the first uh rating in
the world
well actually when I was asked what are
your plans for the match I was uh like
kiding glassing like all right okay I
don't care about the match I want to get
my
2800s and that's probably uh one of one
of the things you know some innocent
joke I was punished for so I guess I had
like
27 27
99.8 which is not enough and that and
that was it so I I don't know about the
first rating um you know the it would be
difficult to to overcome Magnus maybe
maybe he he he he he does this you know
inste instead of me yes so if he keeps
on playing in open tournaments uh I
guess sooner or later he would uh you
know find himself in you know Among The
Mortals uh but yeah I would really I
would really love uh to to get some um
you know uh to get something like 28
plus because of you know especially now
then it's like huge rating deflation
uh because of like okay all all those
all these new Fe F the rules uh I guess
pretty much everyone is losing his
rating right now part of maybe Fabi or
Kar buty they are having like some great
great
season so yeah this would be still quite
quite pleasing but I think this is not
the main the main goal so you know if
you play well you got everything you got
raing you get titles here you get you
get wins and if you play not so well and
you get nothing yeah the the the you
know the goal is the same yeah just to
to to learn to learn chess and to play
well yeah and I wish you to play well in
the tournament so the best of luck for
you thank you for the interview thank
[Music]
you hello I'm women's Grand Master rim
to Jan I will be creating content for
grandest store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping around schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr juny
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s l CH Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it send a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
Al flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the globe
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit world chess h.org
[Music]
we are back with our coverage of round
we're so back and just before the
coverage started Yas is frying a joke on
me so that's why I'm smiling thank you
it wasn't good it was a good one yeah
and uh let's uh remind ourselves for
those you that just joined of the round
three results so far well four games
outstanding but there we see there was a
draw between leevon aronian and Yan
Pachi and uh just to remind everyone
that Yan Kristoff Duda has withdrawn
from the tournament so that means that
lenia Dominguez will be having a buy
today it seems like there's a drawn
virus that is going around here at the
singfield cup because of the three
remaining games uh everything's B except
for that game between Richie rior and
Ali Raza Ali raza's decision of F7 F5
really was confounding we'll have to ask
very much very much looking forward to
the players interview right but the
current position just looks so good for
Richie I mean obviously The Rook is
hanging uh pardon me the Knight is
forking The Rook the Queen the bishop on
B2 is hanging and it seems like Bishop
D4 is absolutely box required uh Peter
he he is reaching for it and yeah he he
will play Bishop D4 uh Queen F6 I was
wondering in the break whether he wants
to gamble with something like Queen F6
Knight takes f8 and now a move of of
some description but what probably drove
him away from this is that would have
been maybe even playable because there's
a lot of counterplay potentially with
Knight A4 coming in but the existence of
the move Queen E8 which forces you now
you you've just sacrificed some material
and now you absolutely have to trade
Queens on F F and then it really becomes
very very attractive because uh that
that wasn't the dream so uh Bishop D4
played white pretty much needs to take
on D4 Knight takes d8 Bishop takes E3
followed by there's also precise move D5
D4 here but it's not even required Rook
takes d8 is also playable this is
clearly a manageable situation for black
so you want to take Knight takes D4 and
before the break we were discussing C
takes D4 Queen takes D4 which is
unbelievably unattractive for black
right I think Rook E8 is a much better
Fighting Chance and which is what you
kind you guys were discussing on the
break and we were trying to discuss it
in sort of human terms without staring
too much at the computer evaluation
which I think Yanka is correctly pushing
me to do more than I'm doing here to be
honest uh I still feel that even without
knowing and I do know by this point what
it says I would feel that white should
be better because I think the whole
position hinges around white
establishing control over the long the
long dark diagonal right so ping the
bishop on E5 eventually black will have
to take on D4 that Bishop will land on
D4 with the bishop on D4 we will we will
no longer really have to worry about our
WR King and it will exert a lot of
pressure uh against the black king so
both Queen G3 and even the immediate
Bishop B5 here I would find Bishop B5
very attractive just for what you're
saying if you now take on D4 just for
argument sake for it and if I do play
Queen takes D4 Queen takes D4 is
playable but Queen G3 is even stronger
to play Bishop takes D4 uh next move
both both are very good the one thing
about the move Bishop B5 is that you
have to calculate Knight D7 you have to
be sure that you're not blundering this
but uh seems to be working out for white
even even Knight F3 seems to be working
there's also this uh this nice little
chipo I'm a piece up yeah not not not
really no after 64 you will have to
continue playing anal material game but
now after Queen F4 we're threatening C
takes D5 we're threatening Queen takes
D4 and we will now within the next few
moves it looks like white will establish
control in the center and once once you
establish control in the center you just
have better pieces and uh with equal
material you will be the side attacking
so I think I mean this is incredibly
sharp but I feel like even without the
the crutches of my magic screen I would
be I would be quite optimistic here with
white rookie eight hasn't been played
yet though and uh incidentally this is
quite an important game for Ali Rua who
is vying for that rating spot in for the
2020 24 candidates cuzz there you see it
the person with the highest rating on
January the 1st will get that candidate
spots to Toronto and we see the live
rating for Ali resa is
2762 but Anish giri there on 27 54 so
not far behind is Wesley so yeah uh we
did see rookie 8 I I wanted to get in
the point that uh after the move Bishop
E5 takes on D4 uh A variation Peter
wouldn't allow me uh Queen takes D4 I
just love the fact that I'm dominating
the long diagonal so much so that my my
own King is really safe right I can put
my king on a and any ideas of Knight to
B6 to C3 uh just it simply doesn't work
i7 is the problem though I think the
reason Queen takes D4 Queen E7 yeah I
think the reason it prefers Queen G3 is
specifically Queen E7 and we might lend
that check on before which we I think as
white would very much like not to allow
also there's a isn't there going to be a
trade for instance um say say you defend
the bishop you Pawn takes yeah Pawn D
take D takes C4
mhm yeah and suddenly well uh moment
just because uh uh things are currently
hanging Bishop takes C4
check uh Knight takes yeah I'm
just you're absolutely right white will
be better but maybe this is somewhat
more manageable for black is the the
full extent of my argument is that we
may be allowing them a little bit too
much I'm not Jud I'm not disagreeing
with your assessment that white is much
better here it's just that maybe you can
be even harsher towards towards the the
black position and that after Queen
E7
uh something very very confounding about
this I must say queen
E7 and I have no tricky
uh none that are immediately available
yeah I don't I don't see anything right
we Rook H1 oh looks looks looks very
logical looks very logical and then
after d takes C4 it seems like there are
no jumps with the bishop on E5 which
because other like Bishop
G7 all of these desirable uh captures
the existence ofen check yeah the
existence of queen queen discourages us
from from that so we do have the current
position with rookie eight also I wanted
to say that the uh game between um mvl
that ending uh you know it's strange if
leavon felt like he left something on
the table I'm really feeling like MV had
his well because maybe this ending was
nothing but I really I could we go back
to before the move Bishop C5 so if I had
played just if MV had played Knight D3
cuz I really wanted to play against the
weak Pawns we had a position on the
board which we thought was fine but
there's also a very clever way of
playing here I think which starts with
the move Rook D2 I see forcing you to
because but the bishop was still on A3
right if on a good Square yeah I'm
trying to get you to place your pieces
on P like specifically the idea of
course is KN C5 A2 right and you will
have to drop back to C1 and you know
among other things I can just go Rook C2
fine of which will of course make a draw
right so I I think objectively black
should be fine I I also think
that because of exactly what Fabby
played Bishop C5 is very much a draw
offer right because after Rook C2 if
you're intending Bishop D4 and it seems
like you are intending Bishop D4 because
this uh like this is exactly the kind of
a position where you might start
regretting regretting your life choices
with A6 A5 being a threat like you can
very easily imagine this suddenly
becoming maybe even a bit better for
black even though currently you you're
just in time to stop A5 and this is
equal uh so he was clearly planning to
play Bishop D4 and as we discussed after
C5 you're pretty much never winning this
game with white but maybe he wasn't
honestly too much
better again one of those Optical uh
Illusions as uh again a a draw suspected
we did leave the position in its current
position with the pawn on G5 and I guess
uh MBL went into a 30-minute oh yeah uh
he is maybe feeling a bit of pressure
here because uh hard to imagine white
honestly playing this sharply for a
win uh Bishop B6 is maybe a move that
indicates that he is thinking of playing
for a win because you know the way to
create a threat here would be to make
sure that B4 cannot be trade at for A6
let's say you put the bishop on A5 and
then you try playing knight7 Knight C5
and picking it up right but that takes
an age and if we imagine F5 probably
gets played Bishop A5 F4 you play Knight
D7 and let's say black decides to
respect the threat and just goes Rook C6
mhm and yes you can put it on C5 but
there is no longer really any point to
it and black has made so much progress
on the other side of the board that uh
equilibrium probably hasn't been shaken
yet but if you imagine the king already
on F5 I'm I'm I'm starting to think that
maybe black is actually playing you
exactly all right so uh this game looks
suspiciously like it's going towards a
draw the game between Wesley so when we
left it it was Bishops of opposite
colors cuz we saw this move G6 Bishop
yeah when we left it the Rooks were
still on the board and they've all been
swapped off and suddenly we're here yeah
king of seven I was liking Wesley's
position a lot actually because you know
he has the possibility to jump into D4
but yeah it looks very very blocked yeah
and that's a British understatement of
the year right
right there is one very sorry horse the
only
one but it is a great defender kns make
good Defenders King's best friend well
if uh the idea from Wesley's perspective
is to play H5 and
G4 try to create a weakness on the F3
Square the Knight is uh
anticipating and any direct attacks
against the F3 Pawn with the Knight on
E1 this looks to my eyes even though I I
understand what you're saying that black
has some pressure on the king side I I
think a draw is just inevitable I don't
think it's enough yeah I don't think I
mean I just can't imagine okay let's
push you King E2 right and now let's
improve the king uh do you want to
improve your bishop or your king it's up
to your your choice what would you like
JY I I don't know what I want but I was
just going to move my king to the center
okay just for fun King F6 let's say
right uh I'll mark time I'll play Knight
to uh C2 and what I really want to do is
remind you that I will have an active
queen I'm going to play the move Queen
A8 or queen
A7 and you're not just going to have
oneway traffic on the F3
Pawn for my personal preference I would
always keep the Knight on E1 and would
already play Queen A8 there right I
think E1 shockingly is the best Square
for that piece uh maybe are you worried
about 94 check maybe and then4 yeah that
that was the reason for my uh slight
delay there Knight to D4 check but
that's not possible because my grand
King F6 ah yes you've left very clever
view
inscrutable uh no the the bishop is
hanging oops Bishop sorry but the idea
is certainly valid like for instance you
know I didn't you didn't have to go King
F6 you could have done your Bishop D7
let's try that one okay Bishop D7 and
again I think uh whether you preface it
with Knight C2 or uh you go immediately
there is a an active Queen and um
well okay now G4 G let's four put you to
the test okay for sure one Pawn gets
traded uh now I have a question though
because you're giving my knight the F3
Square how badly do I want it I don't
know if I want it so badly I'll go Queen
h8 yeah and here I was thinking G G3
okay yeah this is the interesting one
force it to G1 right we are effectively
piss up but do we win well exactly uh
fortunately the the it is active even
though it's trapped on G1 it is hitting
his Pawn on C5 as
uh are the clocks a factor no 20 17
minutes 18 minutes for uh Anish 40 yeah
H5
H3 uh just ensuring that the H pawns get
traded um okay I see that as being a
very balanced game if you don't mind I'm
going to take us right back to fuja as
we've just seen the move Rook E8 and uh
a bit of a think now for Richie is he's
going down to 18 minutes and how many
moves have they made so it was Bishop
Bishop E5 and queen G3 both of those are
strong I'm also only just noticing that
you can include Bishop D Bishop
C7 which we had in a different position
but we haven't discussed here at all but
maybe provoking Queen D7 doesn't really
do anything particularly good for us I
don't know it feels like we've you know
prevented black from playing Bishop B6
but also which might be more relevant
we've protected the G7 Pawn for black
mhm so if we do exactly what we were
planning to do anyway Queen G3 C takes
D4 and Bishop B5 that no longer creates
a threat of mate in one so black is free
to because we cleverly force black to
defend the main threat yeah we we we
absolutely yeah absolutely insisted they
make a useful move so they made a useful
move genius uh I think at the break
sorry Joy you you were suggesting this
idea of Queen G3 and maybe grabbing the
pawn on H6 or threatening it at least
well exactly right so let's have a look
at that so Queen G3 now Black's a piece
down so we presume he wants to capture
the the Knight on D4 now here's the
question for us are we going for the H6
Pawn I wasn't sure about this because
after Queen F6 is a move yeah I think we
start by playing Queen F6 to drive it to
we it goes to G5 I assume the queen
probably goes to C6 it looks right this
is this is where we kind of regret that
we're not lording over the long diagonal
anymore because there are
ideas our King feels exposed it becomes
a race if we could if we could already
play H4 H6 here we are probably mating
black very very quickly
but it takes us two moves so if we go H5
black will probably take on C4 with the
pawn nice Tempo against the bishop H6 C
takes D3 maybe I'm still not convinced
this isn't working to be honest CD3 Rook
D3 I know it's sort of like our Pawn is
really really dominating and we we are a
move away from mating pretty much yeah
once it lands on G7 it feels like we we
no longer need to count pieces which
should be breaking through and
delivering mate on the king side
can you go Bishop B6 I was thinking of
sacrificing on A2 okay away we go yeah
Bishop A2 and my by the way uh our
clever move of oh Bishop C7 is on the
board Bishop C7 is on the board uh our
clever decision of forcing uh black to
make a a decent
move uh was played yeah we should
probably this is a massively try to try
to work out why he
also uh there is a very direct issue
with Bishop C7 which I completely failed
to appreciate in the beginning you can
actually take on D4 and take with a Pawn
on E3 which is quite different than
having massively important because it
allows this simplification and uh why
this is an improvement for black and
this actually once again and this
happens every day and at some point I
will just stop doubting whatever Yanka
tells me MH uh in the break we we got
here and
uh yeah seems like there is a repetition
in the in the game between there we can
see a draw agreed between the
players um I'm not saying that the draws
aren't hard fought they are but in some
cases the the the needle didn't move at
all it was balanced from start to finish
this is one of those games it just feels
like from start to finish nothing
happened and U just
mutually accurate play uh by the players
and yet again the draw virus uh
continues here uh between uh Peter yeah
so so returning to this position Yan was
telling me let's not look at the
evaluation and let's try and figure out
how easy it is to assess and I I kept on
saying that I think I would still take
white here but reard is a stronger
player than I am a much more active
player than I am and a very very sharp
tactical player so should be very much
up his alley the only thing maybe that
was hampering him is being low on time
okay and he burned half his time here
and actually offered an end game which
he is probably not winning so I'm I'm
very much I'm very much accepting that
my evaluation probably was too
influenced by by the the ticker there
and but there's a saying in chess that
The Spectator sees everything kber sees
everything yeah uh Bishop C7 it's such a
a strange move to my eyes because Bishop
E5 is so obviously natural and good I I
I mean yeah maybe I would be looking at
Queen G3 but Bishop C7 would be down the
list I
think we we have to explain about Queen
D7 because apparently I was worried
about both Queen F7 and queen A4 here
but apparently Queen F7 just completely
loses to uh Queen F4 and C takes D4 is
sadly unplayable because of Bishop H7
check which is something that I missed
originally and after Queen A4 the engine
very calmly goes Bishop E6 Bishop B6
Knight E6 and after Knight takes C4
absolutely only move right but wins on
the spot so strictly speaking you cannot
even play Queen D7 Queen D7 is probably
just a losing mistake in but you can
take vience but you can take C takes D4
and if you want to continue with Queen
Zone you have the move Queen F4 or I
guess Queen G3 but probably Queen F4 but
this this is I think very obviously an
inferior version of the positions we
discussing inferior because you now have
to spend that Tempo getting the B and
the Queen on D7 is not poorly placed at
all it has it has a lot of targets on
the queen side this is now a very
unclear very playable position for black
and once again the uh the option of
Bishop takes d8 exists but then you have
to snap on B6 otherwise you worse and
yeah I I don't believe white is better
here no you you will pick up the pawn on
F2 but black will put the Rook on E5 the
king belongs on D6 it looks like this
should be a very manageable end game for
black and you're also not winning this
position for instance very simply
because of this sure and the mass
simplifications are likely to to to end
in in a dreaded draw you know it just
reminded me of a story you know when I
was doing commentary Shaq was playing a
rapid game and he sacrificed his Queen
and we were like oh my God he's
blundered his Queen what is he doing
because we were influenced by the
evaluation bar and uh after the game
finished shakwan and he turned to his
coach and his manager and he said great
game great sacrifice right and goes no
was ridiculous what you did you just
threw away your queen for not that much
right oh oh because I now you reminded
me of a game that was played here in St
Louis and it was between NE
and uh sha RAR and both players had
completely you know misconceived and it
was like minus five it wasn't even close
they had both missed key moments where
the uh where the valuation bar had gone
I remember that yeah
right that postgame interview with shock
is was absolute classic it deserves to
go it deserves to have like millions of
views hasid at some point some point we
showed him line where he basically BL
blundered M and two in some three move
line and he went oh come on that became
a meme for us it was just it was so
great come on come on everything was oh
that was fantastic yeah that was that
was really good uh draw in uh Anish
Wesley just take us there uh Joy tell us
when we left it we thought okay uh
Wesley might press yeah but if you were
going to press here's the turning point
you're going to press with G4 you're not
going to press with H4 H4 is just
locking the position down and here you
go the players managed to find their
repetition they did tell us they're very
good at uh finding the repetition and
very as you said Peter a very balanced
game a correct a correct game uh but now
we go back to this game of uh Richard
for just a moment because from what
everything Peter's just said JY a long
think Bishop C7 question markk just
blunder I mean there goes the advantage
whatever advantages there might have
been they had to be pursued with Bishop
E5 which got my vote I didn't really
think of anything else Queen G3 but a
long thing provoke the move Bishop C7 do
you find that happens often in your own
play that a after a long think you come
up with a mistake yeah wrong thing wrong
thing um yes unless it's particularly
forcing
right you're just making a calculation
because here I just don't understand
what Richard might have overlooked I
take a piece you take my queen why else
did you attack my queen I take your
queen your piece is hanging you take my
Bishop what else well it could also go
back to a basic assumption like often
when you're calculating you think Bishop
attacks queen queen moves moves well and
then you you you get like bogged down
into that Forest where you're thinking
about all the calculations of the queen
to D7 what's going to be happening there
bishop and then once you've kind of
established that you just play Bishop C7
and as soon as you make the move your
brain goes well hang on a second it
doesn't need to move the queen you can
have Pawn takes Knight attacking the
queen and uh and it it could be one of
those cases too Peter where you you
you're looking at a a line you're
dissatisfied it you go look at another
line then you come back and then you
come back to this position and you see
Bishop H7 check something you had missed
and then you go oh of course Happ Play
Bishop C7 to your point you're attacking
the Queen the queen moves and then you
suddenly stop and realize after you've
released the bishop the queen doesn't
have to move yeah I mean I've seen this
mistake in calculation so many times and
I've fallen victim victim to it many
times as well with players as strong as
this I I feel reluctant to suggest but
it feels maybe she was actually missed
because I know that the moment I realize
Bishop C7 existed in my mind it
absolutely forced Queen D7 and I think
what could be the problem here is that
both Queens are already hanging right so
you calculate Rook takes E3 Bishop takes
d8 you realize you will resign in that
position because there is no further
play available you're down hanging down
and at that point you real you say to
yourself okay the queen trade is bad
right so black needs to avoid the queen
trade at all cost so you calculate Queen
D7 you come to the conclusion that Queen
D7 is bad for black and you play Bishop
C7 and then she takes D4 could sort of
fall out of your uh line of uh Vision
Line of vision it's still a bad Miss and
a miss a tactical player of reard cber
the players in action and have a try and
read their body language over the board
let's go to those cameras and uh World
Chess Hall of Fame and see the players
mhm as we see Ali Raza you know if I'm
uh Anish Gary oh he's
reaching he the night there's there was
that a resigns more or less yeah more or
less would need Precision from White
buty 7 would have been bad but you know
as you've been explaining to us joy the
the race for that candidate's spot by
rating is is so important and you know
you you if I'm in anisha's shoes I'm
going over Richard why did you and also
something I wanted to talk about before
reard returns to the board is I wanted
to ask the two of you uh because for me
I don't know I haven't played enough
against reard to know whether this is
something or or nothing but I wanted to
ask you you make a mistake you realize
you made a mistake are you at the board
at that
point or do you actually get up and go
away mostly I'm at the board because I
have sit fles and I just try to or have
a poker face uh throughout the whole
thing what about you at the board you're
at the board no I'm not at the board you
made a mistake you aware of the fact you
made the mistake and then you get up
from the board yeah because because you
don't want to be at the board while your
opponent is thinking yeah I don't I
don't want to actually reveal right to
my opponent that there's something there
I don't want to look in that direction
you know exactly that that is exactly
what I was sort of pointing at perhaps
reard is basically never at the board
when it's not my move but I thought the
fact that he's not there with 15 minutes
on the clock could be an indication that
he quite confidently played Bishop C7 at
some point to dawned on him that Queen
D7 isn't forced and after she takes D4
it's all going in yeah somewhat South
and he decided not to Telegraph it by
sitting there being unhappy uh one of
the two to that issue to what you've
just said uh one of the most
extraordinary examples of blundering at
the board not sitting at the board and
there you have it takes on D4 Bishop
takes d8 by uh Richard uh it was the it
was a
match in bond Germany between Vladimir
karnick and deep Fritz oh yeah the chess
engine and what happened is Vladimir
made a move very confident move signed
it stood up from the board looked at the
position nodded his head grabbed his
coffee cup looked again at the position
was about to go and get himself some
coffee when the operator made made
one you know vad gave us a firstand
recounting of that story I was watching
as a
commentator that was pretty shocking we
very recently played for the same team
Yanka myself and and Vladimir we played
for the chess pensioners team in dorf
and at some point the topic of
blundering M in one came up and vadir
told us the entire story where how he uh
because if not from m in one he would
suddenly be winning in a position which
was very very drawish until that moment
and he thought okay there's clearly some
mistake and he spent like I don't want
to lie about how many minutes but his
move was made in like maybe 10 minutes
and in 10 minutes he still hasn't
spotted Queen B1 H7 m m and he made his
move because in the end he thought okay
I don't understand why I'm being allowed
this chance but maybe there's some
glitch in the in the Matrix you
and then he saw the absolutely shocked
face on the operator and he still
thought it's because the program
glitched and he's now win now m is five
and the crowd was like giving it
away yeah and then and then it lends on
AG s and only at that point he realized
what he's done which is very unusual now
I can tell you the story from the other
side Maus he's in uh the hotel I'm
staying in B and I asked him at exactly
at that moment and uh he explains well
the the the the the screen stopped
working MH the screen stopped working
because M and won there's no more engine
evaluation right this the screen and he
can't understand he's thinking to
himself my God the engine turned itself
off like I I'm stopping it's over and he
go oh because it's m one Queen so his
first reaction was like oh my God
there's a glitch because the engine
turned itself off it was it was the the
glit the glitch on the other side the
glitch on the other we've established
with Yanka our own credentials at least
in that conversation what about you have
you blundered m and one in no I haven't
but uh I I I did yeah but I did have a
very famous game uh which was actually
pretty funny I'm playing John Watson and
I'm like 14 years old he's International
Master John Watson and I'm you know
class e maybe e anyway the point was was
that I'm playing my perk defense and I'm
going B3 B2 A3 A2 I've got two pawns
ready to make queens and he gives me
Checkmate okay so I have nothing else I
could do I promoted a pawn to a King ah
you've done you've done that I've had
that done to me yeah he took my king he
took my king on G8 and he came back and
he took the King was on A1 so I go back
to Seattle and I am very very happy how
did you do I don't care I won four lost
three doesn't matter and I come to this
game and they go
Checkmate and I go no I King my pawn and
I go the the game lasted another 20
moves go yeah sir when you're made it
the game's over said no no no he's an
international Master he knows the rules
better than I
do well I got made it in two game I got
made it twice in one game let's go to
Anastasia I was going to say getting
made it twice in one game not
good so here we are actually so Wesley
welcome to the show the game finished in
the draw with Anish gir important game
like every game in this event of course
so can you tell me I was wondering to
which point you knew the theory let's
switch first all to your game because
we're still analyzing Leon's position so
well I actually knew around until move
11 or move 13 I couldn't remember
exactly but first of all I didn't know
that Anish was going to go for this line
because he's been playing the Italian
yes during the entire rapid and then he
went for the end game the other day
but yeah but similar ideas with Knight
of five I think he likes this one I mean
it's typical for this positions of
course but he brought his Knight also to
F5 in that one yeah but an interesting
game me I play this with both colors and
always seems when the Knight gets to F5
white gets a pleasant position but I
wasn't sure I was thinking for a long
time with
A4 ifess the engine doesn't like it so
maybe what I played this okay mhm I
don't know A4 yeah maybe what I played
was good then because yeah actually I
thought E4 was the way to go sacrificing
a
pawn uh uh but uh yeah I guess black is
just fine here because I have the bishop
there so if whenever the position opens
up I have counter chances like Anish
told me he was considering D4 for a
while and guess black has several good
responses I guess A4 like we looked at
this position briefly right after the
game and it seems black as counterplay
cuz uh the queen is not getting trapped
yeah that's what I'm trying to figure
out like to knight3 you know already
started to see some ideas you know with
Knight E3 yeah and now black is lucky to
have Knight E5 Knight E5 yes okay just
to to be sure that we're not the and
then I can chop off the Knight then now
the queen is safe yes yes so
uh but uh at the end he didn't play this
yes he played Bishop B3 yeah he didn't
like the move Bishop E3 because it seems
a bit slow and now he can never play D4
D4 mhm I thought thought white could go
A4 also for to play in both
wings and then I was calculating
bishop and then play something like that
and now I have to figure out how to
defend the C7
Pawn but guess it's no
problem I saw you on the last for quite
a long time with uh with Anish on the
way here yeah because uh Anish is always
a great player to analyze with he's got
a lot of w them and ideas always is so
was he afraid of any any moment at any
moment what did he think about his
position yeah I guess he wasn't very
happy here black of the bishop there yes
uh I don't know but the position got
real close like I'm not sure how good
this engine is but I also made a mistake
like I played
uh was this stupid engine like giving
it yeah don't really better black better
I'm sure that you uh your knowledge is
better than this engine so don't pay
that much attention to it yeah like
keeping almost minus one but I don't
think yeah maybe here maybe take a
knight B8 I don't know in this position
this moment yes so you always want to
get to D4 right with your knight the
question is at which moment and when or
yes I think I was going to play B4 first
but then I played G6 anyway was very
stupid like Bishop Knight
Knight E3 and I guess it's still a draw
but
uh yeah I guess I guess we I guess it's
just a dra well but maybe here you don't
allow white to have a file I don't know
makes any difference like Bishop just
have and then maybe you keep mean white
has no plans because if he like he has
no real plans like here I could play
Bishop D6 or queen D6 defense s yes mhm
yeah I guess like I play this structure
many times my life yeah so it's
usually uh I know black as the bishop
here but at the same time no way to get
through open the position so easily yes
MH yeah but uh well I mean I didn't want
to lose on a Thanksgiving Day so uh this
this is of course something we don't
like to do yes yes so Happy Thanksgiving
to everyone yes also Havey Thanksgiving
for you Wesley so I guess it's
a pretty solid game but somewhere here
around here there was one moment where
you remember that you started to move
your knight on B8 maybe instead of it
you could have chosen another road
through no no still we had Rooks maybe
yes maybe you could could go through f8
but I was wondering if you were afraid
he will play Bishop H6 trying to
exchange the the Knight to the bishop or
something like that I mean the same idea
but again you keep the a file oh that's
true maybe yeah but was very confused at
this point why Anish Play Bishop C1 to
E3 I got just Rook A1 oh okay and then I
guess I have to play Bishop B7 but at
least now the bishop is blockaded like
generally with D3 E4 you don't want the
bishop there okay maybe like H4 but I
guess just Queen here and uh yeah black
is pretty pretty solid like uh I was a
bit worried during the game My Bishop
could turn bad m the light SC but I
guess Point yes mhm it's uh nothing real
because white needs to get F4 in and
it's just very difficult for him without
allowing I always have counterplay on D3
at the very end let's say could you try
instead of closing the position to push
somewhere G4 instead of like H4 trying
to I mean at the very end like the
moment you somewhere here you know in
descending I mean only you have this
idea to to open the position I'm very
surprised why he didn't play G4 oh he
had this chance I guess he he was yeah I
guess it's I guess he didn't maybe maybe
he didn't wanted to have this H Pawn H5
H for yeah making is very
vulnerable yeah no I
think maybe Magnus would have won this
as black just kid I think it's just
completely dra
because uh if you use a stronger engine
even a slightly stronger it will give
all zeros yeah most probably is but I
mean also my Bishop has no way to yeah
but I was surprised like
uh King
F1 yeah I guess it's just nothing I
thought he was going to go G3 F4 like
but if he plays G3 then maybe he get
some
weaknesses mhm like uh for example if I
get this
position and now maybe I get some some
Bishop D7 yes comes out mhm yeah looks
the Knight is badly placed but
uh but uh with this Pawn structure I had
a very similar Pawn structure with my
game against Magnus in Norway this year
mhm and uh yeah also white white one
structure was impregnable yeah and that
so Wesley one more draw what to do with
this event will anyone deliver a point
you know will score what do you think
told I said before the game I'm very
happy I won't finish last place for
sure okay but uh I mean in all honesty I
I wish Yan Kristoff a speedy recovery I
hope his sickness is not too not to
extreme uh it's just the way the world
is these days you know it's like
everyone's getting sick new new diseases
pop up left and right I saw in the news
the other day and there seems to be some
new respiratory disease in China again
mhm but uh yeah health health is much
more important than chess I wish him
well yeah of course and ever happened to
you that you had you were sick during
the tournament and you had to play when
you really didn't feel
well um nothing that serious fortunately
like I generally finish my tournament I
think I withdrew twice in my life from a
tournament but were open tournaments
maybe I would do two or three times but
it's more of fatigue MH like brain
fatigue uh you didn't play well in this
event so sorry you didn't play play well
in those events yeah like I played in
air Air flat open mhm back in 2011 one
example okay I think 2011 yeah 2011 and
then I had to withdra after six games
just I I couldn't play I played in W
before that and uh it was too too much
so uh it's more like brain fatigue like
I also had to play sometimes when I had
a cold
or in the indiia Olympiad last year I
wasn't feeling well for the first two
rounds but fortunately it wasn't uh I I
I didn't have any serious diseases yet
dur that's good let's hope everything
will be fine with Wesley I'm I'm I'm not
as old
as in the tournament okay thank you so
much all the best of luck for you Wesley
in the next rounds and we go back to the
studio to Jo and Peter thank you
Anastasia and thank you Wesley and
Wesley there showing us his draw against
Anish giri so let's remind ourselves of
the current results it's it's a draw
Fest it is still a draw Fest two games
have finished Anish giri Wesley so as we
saw there and Leon Ronan was slightly
disappointed with his play against
aashi and two games
remaining it feels like these two
remaining games especially the MBL Faby
game that seems to be absolutely headed
for a draw and the game between Richie
and Ali Raa after the mistake uh Bishop
C7 Ali raza's got a new lease on life
and uh he's pretty much okay I would say
he's completely fine and I was honestly
I thought maybe something is wrong with
our with our transmission uh software
because uh if we if we get to the
position they have on the board
currently we left it somewhere around
here if ef2 rook1 expected and I was
playing Rook E5 and trying to bring the
king over to D6 and Al Resa went for
much more concrete plan of trading power
of activating the The Rook y A4 and just
swapping uh F2 for H4 and also losing a
five and here he played Rook B4 check
and I
thought how is Richie thinking play King
C1 and then you think yeah and I thought
honestly I thought maybe something is
wrong with the board because there's
just no way you put the king in the
corner but apparently once again I just
don't understand anything and I should
just stop talking about Chess uh there's
not much Difference In fairness both of
these positions are very very level in
some cases you can even allow the pawn
to reach G7 let me show you uh a
mhm this and it does feel like a three
move three time repetition is occurring
between mvl and uh Fabby so that will be
yet again another draw please 11 out of
11 so far and one left so returning to
our Rook end game yes uh I have
blundered the pawn on C2 here but the
bigger point is let's say you do
something like this yes you you go Rook
C7 you force white to double you go King
F7 and then we will play basically my
idea is to play King E7 attack the pawn
force you to give a check with either of
the Rooks go back back and say now your
Pawn is hanging sir would you like would
you like to go back right so black has a
lot of leeway here uh you are not at all
obliged to allow the pawn to to to land
on D7 but you can if if you absolutely
must and the way perhaps not to allow it
comfortably is this very clever move
Rook B4 B5 pinning it on the fifth for
now and then bringing the Rook over to
C5 perhaps putting the Rook on d8 black
is just frankly untroubled he's gone
with Rook d8 immediately just now as we
were
uh discussing this position seems maybe
not to be the most precise move once
again I should stop even looking at this
because if if I wasn't looking at the
slight fluctuations of the evaluation I
would say quite reasonable pretty much
any legal move in this position that
doesn't allow white a lot of immediate
progress right will make a draw and I
think we should stand by by that
assessment and this uh game definitely
does look like it's heading to a draw
and I'm thinking about uh
you know so many draws uh probably the
single craziest tournament I've ever
seen in terms of draws was a strange
larus event in uh back in my day there
were two types of events there were
events with Gary Kasparov there were
events without Gary Kasparov that was it
and Gary played in the tournament I
think it was a six player double round
robin and essentially he won against
every opponent one game and Dro drew the
other game and everybody else Drew I
remember that it was like crazy
everybody else drew the the only
decisive play was Gary and he won all
the games I mean it was just like really
crazy yeah I I think there's two two
incredibly similar uh cross tables from
U maybe the late late '90s and the early
2000s where this is exactly the final
the final cross table Gary on plus five
and everybody else in minus one exactly
um I think there's actually more than
one of those I I have this this weird
memory of seeing two of those yeah and
by the way after the move Rook d8 by Ali
Raza uh Richie said look the only Trump
I have is my dwn let me push it why he
needs to do it with his King on A1 and
not his King on Sean that's will remain
a mystery until we talk to the players
and ask him why he did that but D6 yeah
I think Rook D7 is very logical right
Rook D7 Rook C4 I like Rook D7 too that
looks very yeah logical Jump In Joy yep
yeah I was just wondering you know this
position looks very level so I mean how
does white secure the draw how does
white secure the draw okay for if you
were to go Rook to E5 you know threaten
Rook e why don't you're not even
threatening Rook E7 I'm not threatening
Rook E7 no uh you threat okay so let's
say I go Rook to C4 and I think we very
much get the a similar idea of what
Peter was saying you're going to
approach the depond with your king and
I'm going to wait for you to do that and
as soon as you play King e x I'm going
to suggest check and you'll move your
king and then the Haring of the point
the way I can see this not being a draw
exactly like the one Yer is describing
would
no let's continue along the same lines
let's put this position with a doubl
drook on D5 let's put the Rook let's
make some yeah let's go like Rook D5 D3
here yes dropping it and black goes uh
let's say King E8 King E8 yeah okay I'm
trying to I I don't think white has any
winning chances I think so you want to
put the king you want to change so let's
say we continue making in different
moves we go I don't know A3 or something
yeah yeah King B3 Black Goes Rook F7 and
then you allow King D7 okay and then
maybe you could experience some
discomfort right because that position
the D6 Pawn becomes a Target black could
also maybe start expanding on the king
side but there are ways not to let that
happen ever right well even this Peter I
must say that after for example D7 check
you're going to put your King on d8 most
certainly um how do I do it with I I get
my Rook to the sixth rank right so that
I'm willing to trade off the D7 Pawn for
the B Absolut Pawn the players have been
making some moves A3 on the board Let me
refresh My My by the way I saw yeah okay
Ali Raz is beginning to speed up the
tempo of his moves I think the the
Perpetual that we've been describing for
a while now is very much incoming I
think both of them realized that yeah I
think he'll play something like Rook G3
or Rook 5 G2 here very very quickly
right and then King E6 six jck King F7
is very likely to happen because this
really does look like a position that
nobody wins ever although I must say I
don't see
any fears if we do have Rook D5 D3 I
agree King E6 is a repetition but King
E8 just basically saying I I think the
issue here is I will play Rook E3 check
okay and if you go King d8 I will put
the Rook on G6 and I will ask you are
you actually playing for a win with my
Rook on G6 being as active as it is Rook
to G3 or Rook E6 G6 or oh pardon me Rook
E6 to G6 pardon me both of those seem
like very very logical and I'll put my
Rook on f77 let's say I don't living
life on the edge yes and uh we get
something like this and I put the other
Rook on D2 so that I never blund a rook
F2 gotcha and then who's ever going to
make progress here
right uh look looks like a draw and view
but well we're going to keep an eye on
this game but in the meantime we are
going to go to Anastasia who has a
special guest with
her yes indeed welcome Fabiano Carana is
here with us in the studio the game with
Maxim R gr just finished in a draw uh
not
surprisingly for for this tournament so
far so how would you assess your
participation at the moment in this
event yeah it's a bit of a strange
tournament I missed a huge chance
yesterday completely winning uh during
the game I started to feel absolutely
exhausted for some reason MH like I
couldn't calculate a single move and I
was trying to sit there trying to
calculate and then I got low on time and
uh yeah that yesterday was a big Miss
today I think was a very stable game how
was it to play Thanksgiving by the way
Happy Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving
yeah it's uh well you know we've as
chess players we play during all sorts
of days and I've played on my birthday
and during you know Christmas as well
yeah and all sorts of occasions so it's
not too unusual and I think night will
be a nice
celebration um yeah but and at least I
didn't lose that that's that's the main
thing yeah that's important yes game I
think also it's important it was an
important game yes by the way the game
between Richard Robert and D Resa just
finished in the draw yes after
repetition so sorry for this break let's
let's come back to this one I think it
was also important for the standings and
for over standings of gr chur have you
thought about it a little bit not too
much it's again very
unusual a player withdrew well out of
necessity young Kristoff got ill in some
way so hopefully he recovers but again
very unusual yet so like like last year
we're missing a player from the
tournament so it's for me it's a bit of
a strange situation because I'm going to
have three blacks in a row yeah um which
okay I I guess it's not the biggest deal
but but uh it's very unfortunate of
course for the tournament and also I
feel bad for for young Kristoff because
it's um yeah it's always unpleasant to
come all this way and you know you get
ill or or something like that and you
can't play anymore so so that's quite
unfortunate yeah it's affected also your
situation I think now there are no
chances that you will end up in the last
place I'm sorry to say so I don't think
it was the case but I mean um worst case
scenarios are not possible anymore yeah
yeah that's true um but I anyway I'm
hoping not to have a bad tournament so
we'll see so far everyone's having the
same tournament maybe maybe we'll be one
big happy family at uh at the end of the
tournament here in first through last
place you knowen this possibly yes it's
probably not going to happen but I think
today we played a correct game like I I
don't think anything happened that was
special it was a bit sharp um but okay I
think this is kind of known Theory um it
was played in rep in Blitz they
mentioned the game actually was played
kuang and and Ali Resa play the game mhm
but I think that Maxi made it
interesting at this moment because I I
think that the game between Ali Resa and
L kuang laang was white was like was
like this something like this basically
I forget exactly which uh version they
got this end game in but it was this end
game which is equal and Maxim made it
interesting with this move uh leads
Again by force to to this situation with
uh
with like two pieces versus rook and and
versus Rook yeah I get the pawn by force
quite important
mhm and I I think it's kind of forcing
because like he doesn't want to get this
kind of situation where if I put my Rook
on C2 he's suddenly stuck he can't move
his pieces and also Bishop C1 I can take
on F2 but also I have this move Rook C2
I wasn't 100% sure but I calculated some
lines where I'm you know grabbing this
pawn and then very often I also grab
this Pawn where I play like C5 here and
my a pawn becomes very fast but also I
thought I can take on F two when did you
get this ending what was your feeling
like you were a bit shocked or it was
kind of normal no well I kind of knew
that it's possible and I didn't know the
details but I figured that it's equal
and it was easy to figure out the lines
like I was calculating various moves
here of course white
has actually there was like an option to
play Rook C2 I think but then this was
kind of important I think that Bishop B
before Rook
E2 then something he has his Knight D3
this is very unpleasant and then he gets
this one and he attacks C7 as well so I
take here and yeah I was looking at some
various moves here like Knight D7 trying
to get to C5 um but always I can attack
his pawns like Knight D7 Rook
C2 um or or even Rook A2 very often is
coming and uh and then yeah if The
Bishop's on B4 I have A5 and okay I
wasn't surprised by this but this leads
to a foreen sequence cuz I liquidated
some Pawn so here it's clear that black
cannot really risk too much here because
it's only one Pawn left and for him to
capture this Pawn there's only one way
he has to put the bishop on A5 and
Knight on C5 CU if he puts Knight on B8
like let's say here he plays Knight D7
F5 Knight B8 then he gets in trouble
with with A4 A5 sorry I guess it's not
real trouble but I thought okay maybe my
Pawn runs to A4 or maybe I can just
trade pawns with the draw mhm so there's
so he needs to put the bishop on A5 in
order do it to block the pawn right yeah
there's no other way like also Knight C6
I can I can move my king like King H7 I
thought and again Knight the5 yes so so
he put the bishop there I was kind of
expecting knight7 first but I don't know
if it makes a difference okay here I was
like looking at various moves they all
looked like a draaby um like I thought
F4 first but then I thought maybe H4 I
don't know maybe H4 like if GH4 then
suddenly gets the Stable Square for his
Knight which of course is also a draw um
and if King G7 I thought maybe H5 it's
the KN on G4 okay I didn't anyway with
the Knight on G4 he can't move but I was
like trying to be super super accurate
okay I played Rook C2 so now H4 I just
Advanced my king there's no point and
okay he went here here King G1 because
I'm threatening F3 and we just repeated
moves I was thinking some time about H5
here with the point that okay Knight C5
then G4 take take Knight A6 G3 M anyway
King F1 I didn't see forward but at
least here like he has to maybe if you
go to Gan King F3 yes yeah yeah and then
he goes to to like G4 for example okay
here I actually don't want to do this
because now I'm the one who has to prove
the draw but then I was thinking well
yeah I play H5 and he plays King F1 so
G4 is not possible so I play like King
F7 Knight C5 G4 take take again Knight
A6 G3 but then I thought Knight D3 and I
was like maybe I'm losing my F Pawn like
G3 Bishop B6 so he has TR Knight F4 and
I thought anyway like worst case this
position like everything is a draw at
this moment because okay he's left with
one Pawn but why should I do this so I I
just played Rook C1 King F2 and
just yes of course I mean it's also
Thanksgiving today um I was wondering if
you saw this tweet from Magnus yesterday
that he was celebrating like 10th
anniversary of winning the world
championship title and he also published
this photo where he jumped inside of the
swimming pool fully I mean with his
clothes on and so Fabby at the moment
when you become the World Champ what are
you going to do what is the craziest
thing you are you will do let's agree
from now oh wow the craziest thing I
don't know I can't uh I can't say yet I
think this has to be spontaneous right
yes maybe but but um if if I I don't
think it's like when because I think
it's more if but if I become world
champion someday then uh then and
definitely I'll do something crazy I'm
not sure yet let's keep it spontaneous
exactly okay I hope I'll will be invited
to take some photos of course course I
agreed it will be some uh well we don't
know what it will be but no I thought
that um yeah Magnus had a good
celebration of course in 2013 I think
there was also some people who like when
it was Winter uh let's say in V gen if
they won the tournament they would like
jump in the North Sea yeah yeah I
remember such bets yesh so this is kind
of crazy I mean you know you don't want
to like win a tournament and then you
get carried out into the North Sea and
nobody ever sees you
again so maybe there's some like safer
sa to celebrate yeah yeah Magnus did it
by jumping in the uh in the fountain
right this is a bit safer yes yes yes
for sure I mean you'll have the
candidates on April yes in Canada so
maybe we can also discuss this but okay
let let me give you the chance to
celebrate properly thanks given thank
you so much Fab for the interview and
all the best in the next rounds thanks
thank you uh Anastasia and because it's
Thanksgiving let's wind it up Peter uh
final thoughts of the
finsing my my impassion speech about
variance is looking dodgier and dodgier
by the second it's the accuracy and
strength of the field and also fatigue
apparently because Fabi was completely
exhausted yesterday and couldn't
calculate we just heard it from the
horse's mouth true B uh whatever the
reason is it's 12 out of 12 so far and
yeah we are we are entering territory
where we will at some point need to find
plausible reasons for this I don't quite
understand what's going on apart from
once again restating the fact that this
is a very very strong field this is the
the absolute best in the world playing
against each other and this is not as
statistically improbable as all that but
still 12 in a row 12 in a row my pick
mvl we're all singing
Kumbaya because nobody has the lead
quote from Fabiana Carana everybody's
having the same tournament perhaps
everyone will be a happy family by the
end of it and there you can see there's
a big tie there for first place of one
and a half points and the only reason
that the three players are on one point
it's because Yan Kristoff dudah has
withdrawn from the event and their
results have been nullified well as we
uh go to our Thanksgiving uh turkey
dinner we want to wish our AUD audience
are very Happy Thanksgiving as well
thank you for joining us same time same
channel tomorrow we'll help you join us
byebye Happy Thanksgiving byebye see you
[Music]
then this has been a presentation of the
St Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited